We are convening for the May 9th session and I'm going to begin when everyone is quiet.
Thank you very much.
I'm going to begin with announcing the results of closed session.
In closed session the board discussed on the following case, Thrive Public Schools versus SBE.
We're going to move on to regular consent items.
And there are two separate consent votes since we have multiple recusals for item 14.
So we're going to start with items 5 through 13.
And do we have any public comment on items 5 through 13?
Yes, we have one person signed up for item six, Angela Doramos, and one signed up for item 12, Rick Loya.
OK, shall we have public comment?
Good morning.
We did.
Former mayor of Huntington Park where yes I had to chair over meetings where we had 20 and 30 people come and yell at us.
One time we even had 75.
But for what you folks dealt with yesterday it just shows
the system works and I just wanted to congratulate you for letting everyone speak, everybody got their two cents in, some may not be happy with the results but the process did work and as a former health teacher I'm just delighted now this
The thing can go along and the framework can come out and someday there'll be a health education requirement somewhere where that framework will really nail things down.
So you did a fantastic job, especially the chair who times up, times up, and that was super.
Congratulations.
Angela Doramos.
Are there public comments?
I think we are, unless there's any other discussion, we are ready to vote.
Can I have a motion?
I'm asking for a motion.
I move approval.
Thank you.
Second, thank you.
All in favor, say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed, nay.
Any abstentions?
Okay.
All right, we're losing our several folks.
Now this is item 14.
And is there any public comment on this item?
Item 14.
All right, with no public comment, any discussion?
I need a motion to approve.
Thank you, and a second?
I'll second.
Thank you very much.
All in favor, say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Any abstentions?
All right, so moved.
All right, so I'm told I have to bang the hearing when we start a public hearing, the gavel.
Okay, public hearing commences.
No, we don't have to.
Oh, after your presentation.
OK, thank you.
Get to bang it more than once.
That's great.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
It's the most fun part.
All right.
Good morning, President Darlingham and board members.
My name is Lisa Constancio.
I'm the director of the Charter Schools Division.
And I'm here to present item number 15, Eagle Collegiate Academy that has an appeal before the state board for an establishment of a charter school.
Ed Code section 47605 defines what is before us.
Basically, it is the education code that states how we look at establishments and new petitions for establishment of a charter school.
It states that the governing board of a school district, and in this case, the state board, shall not deny a petition unless it makes written findings.
And it needs to make at least one of the following written findings.
Our charter school presents an unsound educational program.
The petitioners are demonstratively unlikely to successfully implement the program.
The petition does not contain the required number of signatures.
The petition does not contain an affirmation of specified assurances.
And the petition does not contain reasonably comprehensive description of the 15 required elements of the charter.
I just wanted to lay this out in the beginning so we can reference back to it if we need to as we go through the presentation.
The Department of Education recommendation is the State Board hold a public hearing to deny the request to establish Eagle Collegiate Academy, a kindergarten through 12th grade charter school under the oversight of the State Board.
The recommendation is based on the following findings, that they are demonstratively unlikely to successfully implement the program based on an unrealistic financial and operational plan,
This includes aggressive enrollment projections and an unviable facility plan and also that one of the current the charter elements is is Not fully fleshed out and that is the one for employee qualifications
Timeline here, on November 8th, 2018, the Actin-Aguadulce Unified School District voted to deny the Eagle Collegiate Academy petition by a vote of three to zero.
On December 18th, 2018, the Los Angeles County Board of Education voted not to take action on the petition by a vote of six to one, and I'll talk a little bit more about that later in the presentation.
The petitioners submitted a petition on appeal to the state board on July 29th of 2019.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools met on April 10, 2019.
The Advisory Commission moved staff recommendation to deny the petition to the State Board of Education.
The motion passed by a vote of 5 to 2 with one abstention.
Past history, the Eagle Collegiate Academy has made multiple attempts to become locally authorized.
The petition was submitted to two different school districts, Sulphur Springs, which denied them in 2016, and then Actin Aguadulce Unified denied the petition twice, in 2017 and then in 2018.
Each of the times they went before the district, they also then subsequently went before the County Office of Education in Los Angeles.
So in December 2017 and then July of 2018, LACO denied the petition both of those times.
On the third time, the most recent one in December,
they voted to take no action.
And they voted to take no action.
The staff report stated that the current petition contained few changes from the previous ones that they had seen, which is why at that point they decided to take no action on the petition and then subsequently were able to appeal then to the State Board.
Just a quick summary of the district and county findings, inadequate description of educational program, insufficient description of performance goals, insufficient description of key staff positions, lacked assurance of ADA accessibility, detailed safety policy and procedures, and then unclear admission criteria related to the international baccalaureate program.
The petitioner did state that each time the petition has gone through, has been up, they have gone through multiple revisions in response to the feedback they've received from the district and county and have made adjustments in areas of finance, the educational program, and their charter elements.
The school proposes to open this fall in 1920, serving kindergarten through eighth grade initially with 355 students, including 15 pupils in pre-K for three and four-year-olds.
They are proposing to grow to serve 555 pupils in kindergarten through grade 12 by 2023-24, and they do intend to locate in the boundaries of the Actin-Aguadulce Unified School District.
The mission of Eagle Collegiate is to empower pupils to become self-confident, egalitarian, and authentic global citizens preparing for the 21st century careers and responsibilities.
They plan to become an IB school and outline the IB continuum implementation timeline for primary years, middle years, diploma program that is aligned with the common core standards.
In terms of our findings, the findings are in inability to implement the program.
The school is fiscally viable based on the budget they have submitted to us.
They have positive ending fund balances and reserves.
Our concern is to be fiscally viable.
The budget plan requires that they meet this enrollment projection of 355 students in their first year of operation.
We are concerned about this aggressive enrollment projection.
They are proposing to open with 355 students in TK through grade 8 in the first year.
They do then plan to add high school one year after that in each subsequent year.
So they plan to add grade nine through grade 12, one grade per year over the next four years of the charter term, and proposing to go from 355 students to 555 students within that five-year window, which is a 63% increase over that five years.
while also implementing this international baccalaureate program, which can be complex and does require a lot of teacher professional development.
The petitioner has stated that they have received 400 meaningful intent to enroll forms from parents.
The aggressive enrollment projections are also compounded by the size of the school district in which the petitioner is proposing to locate.
Actin-Aguadulce is a small school district.
They serve approximately a little over 1,000 pupils, comprised of one elementary school, one middle, and one high school.
Their average enrollment by grade of each of these is between 50 and 100 pupils.
The majority of the enrollment at this school district is for non-classroom-based charter schools.
In terms of the facility, we do have some concerns here as well in terms of their ability to implement.
The petitioner is currently in negotiations to lease the property in the boundaries of Acton Agua Dulce.
At the April 2019 Advisory Commission meeting, they stated that in its current state, the property has the capacity for four classrooms.
But in order to accommodate 355 pupils, they'll need to add at minimum at least an additional 13 portables by August of 2019.
So they have budgeted $275,000 in tenant improvements and in modular costs for July of this year and an additional amount for July of 2021.
And they did state at the Advisory Commission meeting also that they had not considered the following costs, which was additional portables needed for the first year of operation,
expansion and renovation costs, time and cost to obtain applicable permits, and then time and cost to renovate to meet the building code standards for e-occupancy, which is required for a state board authorized school.
So the petitioner has submitted some subsequent information that I'm sure she'll be speaking to when she comes up.
We are still very concerned about the time it will take to do this.
And even, pardon me, with just the e-occupancy alone, there is renovation involved in the current building that involves firewalls and things that do take time and do take additional costs.
So we are concerned about that all being done by August 2019.
Also in terms of deficiencies in the charter elements, there is a deficiency in employee qualifications in terms of the petition identifying what's key in each category and specifically the additional qualifications expected of individuals assigned to these positions.
So with the complexities of implementing an IB program for TK through grade 8 in the first year, this element is of particular importance in implementing the educational program and the essential staff that's needed to be identified.
Professional development, as I mentioned, of an IB teacher is extensive, so the section does talk about personal professional development, but it doesn't speak to the significant amount needed for teachers to implement this type of program.
In summary, CDE staff is recommending denial due to the written finding would be inability to implement the program based on an unrealistic operational plan, aggressive enrollment and facility concerns, and the clarification of the charter element in the petition would be needed.
So that's the end of my presentation.
Are there any questions I can answer at this time?
Yes, sir.
Thanks, Lisa.
I appreciate your always thorough review of your findings.
Just a couple of technical questions, I think.
One, you mentioned on the findings page about inability to implement the program.
And I just want to make sure I understand this.
The majority of the enrollment in Acton, Agua Dulce, in the school district, is that of the 1,080 students?
The majority of that is non-classroom based?
No, I should clarify, I'm sorry I didn't clarify that.
The 1,080 students is within the district.
They have, if you look them up in the directory there's about 15,000 students in the district.
The majority, the remainder of those are what is the non-classroom based enrollment.
Okay, but not the 1,080.
Correct.
From charter schools?
Yes.
Can you, because they have many charters.
Is that homeschooling?
What does that mean?
OK, within the district, classroom-based charter schools.
I'm sorry.
Within the district, classroom-based schools, the enrollment in those three schools, the elementary, the middle, and the high school is the 1,080.
If you pull up the district in the directory, I think the enrollment is over 14,000, almost 15,000.
The difference there between that and the 1,080 are non-classroom-based charter schools that have been authorized by the district.
They have many charters at this district.
They're all operating non-classified.
Is that virtual?
What does it mean to be non-classroom based charters?
It's primarily, yeah, go ahead.
It is primarily resource centers.
So there are resource centers that students can come in for one-on-one independent study type programs with a teacher.
I have a list, I'll go back and take a look at my list of all the schools that, I pulled up the district so I'd have that with me, but they could be homeschool programs as part of the independent study as well, but it looks like the majority are resource centers that are located, authorized by the district, can be located within those district boundaries.
just a couple, one more, on the facility, because as you appropriately noted, the bulk of the conversation at ACCS had to do with availability of facilities.
So I just want to clarify that in order to accommodate the 355 pupils, there need to be an additional 13.
And I just, then the next one, your next slide says that they've budgeted 275.
in tenant improvement and modular costs for July 19 and 275 for July.
Would that cover the additional 13 portables or not?
If they're going to lease the portables, I think they can accommodate leasing the portables with a portion of that.
The part that's unsure is the renovation costs because there could be I don't know until our facility people get out there if there are ADA issues that will need to be addressed.
Just for, I can tell you from my old facility days, just certification of occupancy for the E, they have to build firewalls in order to meet that building standard.
There are additional costs for that as well.
And this is all outside of the permitting, because there's permitting for zoning.
Right now it's a church.
So to change the conditional use permit, that isn't as big of a deal to do, but it is to make it an E occupancy building,
There are renovation costs that are going to be involved in that.
And I don't know the extent of those without taking a look at the building itself.
And I'm not sure if they know to that extent yet either.
OK.
There are clarifying questions right now.
We'll get those.
Then we'll get the public hearing.
Yes, Matt.
In relationship to the facility costs and the expectations, I'm clear in my understanding that they want this to happen in two months, August.
Yes.
Any questions?
Yeah.
My question was on the statement you made concerning the personnel.
Is the personnel you're speaking about the actual classroom teachers, or is it other personnel that's the issue?
The teachers.
Okay.
I'll ask for other details later, but I wanted to make sure I understood what you were asking.
Now I do the gavel.
Now I convene the public hearing.
If there is public comment, do we have a?
Petitioners have time, okay.
The petitioner will have 10 minutes and then we will hear from the district and the county if they're here.
I'm not sure if they're here.
They together have 10 minutes as well.
Then we'll hear general public comment which will be one minute and then we'll close the public hearing.
That's not your presentation.
That's all right.
Okay, so we have... That's that.
This one here?
Ah, got it.
Good morning, honorable Madam President, Dr. Darlene Harmon, and honorable board members.
On behalf of our team, families, and community who are anxiously waiting for your decision, thank you
for taking the time to review our petition and to hear our appeal today.
And thank you also to the CDE staff.
We know it was a lot of work to read.
My name is Ogokoye Johnson.
I am the board secretary and founder of Eagle Collegiate Academy.
I am here with Dr. John White, who is our CEO and veteran administrator.
We will start our presentation by sharing with you a two minutes quick video showcasing our lead teachers and families.
Honorable Commissioners and Board Members, I am Eliana Howe, Family Teacher and ELD Coordinator for ECA.
I have attended several district and county board meetings to advocate for this wonderful school.
Please approve our school.
Thank you.
My name is John Sokeke, Special Education Director for Eau Claire Jeter Academy.
Many parents of students with learning differences have shown interest in this school.
Honorable Board Members, please approve this school.
Honorable Commissioners and Board Members, I'm Elizabeth Chislett, the Art Teacher and IB Coordinator for Eagle Collegiate Academy.
On behalf of our teachers, students, and community, please approve our phenomenal school.
Thank you so much.
Honorable Commissioners and Board Members, I am here for the Korean families in Antelope Valley, Santa Clarita Valley,
and San Fernando Valley, who have been waiting for Eagle College Academy to open.
It is an excellent educational program, and the location is perfect and ideal for our families.
Please approve Eagle College Academy for our families.
Thank you.
We are the Michaels, and we support ECA!
Don't stop this unique opportunity for all children and families.
Hi, my name is Edwin Resinos.
I am the pastor of City on a Hill Church.
I am here with Dr. Ogo, and this is our congregation who are asking you to please approve Eagle Religion Academy.
And the people said,
I do it.
Thank you and I'm glad you do it.
I also want to draw attention to the letter that Senator Scott Wilk, the vice chair of the Education Senate Committee here, wrote.
This was handed out to you.
I just want to point attention to that so that you are aware that he wrote this letter.
I also want to state just quickly that during the second time we were at LACO, it was a no action.
There was a vote of three to two.
And so LACO actually did not take action during that time.
The foundation of ECEA is influenced by the tapestry of grit that defines my life experiences to overcome against all odds as an immigrant raised by a single father who taught me to work hard after the death of my mother.
my passion for equity and social justice, and to eliminate all gaps, achievement, opportunity, and graduation, so that zip code and economic status will not hinder any child from receiving a quality education.
Our locally grown, locally owned, and locally operated resilient team of passionate professionals, parents, and educators are very humbled by our 407 families overwhelming confidence in us.
So we answer their mandate for education choice.
We know that hundreds of families have sent you emails and have called on behalf of ECEA.
So that is why we are here today.
In researching the best instructional model that will meet the needs expressed by our families, we chose a career-to-career model that answers these four basic questions.
For what future are we preparing our students?
What skills and attributes will students need to be successful in this future?
What will schools do to prepare students in this future?
How can schools, families, and communities work together?
And hence our mission, Eagle Collegiate Academy will empower students to become self-confident, independent-minded, egalitarian, authentic, lifelong learners and global citizens that are prepared for 21st century careers and responsibilities.
And in order to accomplish that, our mission, we have to use these following best practices in front of you.
Our chosen facility is zoned C3, and it does not need a conditional use permit.
And in order to turn it to a school, we submitted a zoning verification letter and a chart from the LA County Department of Regional Planning to you.
We also submitted a letter from the lead engineer to you.
The portable and modular classrooms that come ready with e-occupancy do not need anything done to it.
It will be leased, and the lease is within our budget.
We are confident we will be ready to open by September 30th at the latest.
So here are the letters that we sent you just as a reminder.
In our response to CDE staff report, we did submit the 80% budget.
And we appreciate staff for making the correction that we submitted.
And they found both our budgets to be viable.
Here is a sample of the Charter Asset Sample Proposal showing that we have the cash needed to open.
Although we lost the public charter school grants of up to $475,000 because we were not approved by March 14, 2019, we will reapply for it.
We have applied for other grants, including $35,000 for Brett Mayer grant with skilled grant writers, and we will keep applying for grants that we are eligible for.
Our enrollment growth is not to cover expenditures, but to meet the instructional program that we want, pre-K through 12th grade school.
The proposed location is reasonably priced facility at the border of Algodolce and Kenyon country.
Acton-Algodolce Unified School District happens to be the only K through 12 school within our community.
Most interested families are from Santa Clarita.
Although not required, due to families' continued interest, we were able to collect 159 signatures between April 1 and April 7 to demonstrate interest.
We are confident that we will meet our enrollment.
A breakdown of the number of applicants per grade level based on parent interest is demonstrated below.
ECA has the staff and teachers in place, such as the experienced CEO, school administrative assistant, in addition to already highly qualified teachers.
In the summer of 2018, we posted positions and we received 540 applications in the summer of 2018.
And we were able to hire staff ready to begin.
ECA team has deep knowledge of IB, professional development, and we will work closely with the IB to make sure that teachers and school leaders are trained.
Mr. Phil Evans was here and he fielded many questions during the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools meeting in April.
Element five, we didn't use the word key, but we met all the other legal requirements and affirmations.
And we identified key positions and we put down the specific qualifications for them.
So ECA will continue to make all the revisions to the charter petition that CDE requires.
So why do we need ECA?
It will be the first and only pre-K through 12 IB wall school in Santa Clarita.
It will support parents with before and after school.
It will eliminate huge gaps in the CASP scores that is found in the transitional grades such as 3 and 7 in all really our local schools in the area.
It will provide more access to rigorous college prep classes, and it will definitely eliminate or lower the chronic absenteeism that is very rampant in our area.
So rampant that it's higher than the county and the state averages.
Here are the chronic absenteeism rates.
For the county, you can see that.
You can see the demographics over here.
And you can see that the rates for the districts are higher than that of the state and county.
When you drill it down to the subgroups, you can see even more dire results in terms of chronic absenteeism in this area.
So here is our credit to career vertical articulation structure.
And as you can see, we have lower school, middle school, upper school, and we have career electives that we offer.
And the relevant research that we have paid attention to, there are a few of them, are here, and you can see who created those research.
And so, we are ready to open, and we ask you to please listen to the voice of the parents who have been working hard to bring this to the community and approve our petition, thank you.
And we are here if you have any questions for us.
So we'll have the county office.
Thank you.
Good morning board.
Thank you for having us here today We are here.
My name is Nishay Patterson.
I am the current director of charters for Acton Agua Dulce Unified School District And I just want to give you a little background on what our team does We are comprised of myself who is the director of charter schools We have assistant superintendent of business services Lynn David and the superintendent Larry King.
We are the ones that make
recommendations to the board on any petitions, renewals, anything that has to do with the charter.
So we make the recommendations to the board and we report on various charter matters.
Our recommendations to the board trustees are based on a matrix that's used as a tool to analyze and evaluate our charter petitions.
The petitions that comply with the law and demonstrate a sound, unique instructional program and present a viable fiscal plan may be recommended for approval to our board.
Eagle Collision Academy's petition was denied due to the petitioner's failure to meet those guidelines.
The basis to deny the Eagle Collegiate Academy charter petition is based on findings that the petitioners are demonstrably Unlikely to successfully implement the program set forth in the petition and the petition fails to include reasonably comprehensive descriptions of all of the 15 elements identified in the ed code 47 605 B 5 and
The petition presents an unrealistic financial and operational plan and an unrealistic plan for the proposed educational program.
The proposed financial and operational plan is unreasonable because it contains expenditures that appear to be unreasonably low.
It relies on aggressive initial enrollment and aggressive growth to cover its projected expenditures.
As mentioned before, our enrollment, our seat-based programs, are approximately 1,080 students that we have in the Acton-Aguadulce area.
We are on declining enrollment.
We have approximately 400 students enrolled.
maximum at each site.
We have one elementary, one middle, one high school.
We have 376 students at our elementary school.
We have 360 in our middle school.
And we have 371 in our high school.
So we have very low numbers.
So the projected number of being able to start a program with 355 students
It's extremely high.
It relies on borrowing based on that ADA to manage cash for three years and projects a reserve that will not meet requirements in the first year of enrollment, does not materialize for startup costs to prove to be under budgeted.
The petitioners are demonstrably unlikely to success I'm sorry successfully implement the program set forth in the petition because they present an unrealistic educational plan The petitioners proposed to implement an international baccalaureate IB program But the petition does not demonstrate enough familiarity with the program with the IB program and although they had a person come up from the IB Program itself the
Experience that their teachers would need and based on what they projected as a starting pay rate for teachers doesn't really line up with Beginning pay for teachers that have that type of experience that would be implementing an IB program The petition does not contain enough detail about IB program implementation to give staff confidence that the petitioners be successful
In addition, we found deficiencies in their educational program, their measurable student outcomes, employee qualifications, health and safety, and admissions requirements.
Any questions?
Is the county here?
Oh, the county, yeah, they are here.
Thank you, President Hammond and board members.
My name is Indra Lopez-Ciccarelli.
I am the director for the charter school office at the Los Angeles County Office of Education, or LACO.
Eagle Collegiate Academy, or ECA, has made four unsuccessful attempts to obtain a district-level charter, as noted on the screen.
ECA also submitted three appeals to the Los Angeles County Board of Education, following denial by each district.
The county board denied the first petition by a vote of 5 to 0.
The county board took no action on the second appeal with a split vote of three to two in favor of denial.
On this third appeal, the county board voted six in favor and one in opposition to specifically take no action with regards to this third submission to the county.
LACO staff did review this latest petition, but as the county board did not take action on this latest position, staff is here today to share the findings of the Los Angeles County Review Team rather than any findings made by the board.
County staff found only minor revisions between the three submissions and determined that all three petitions failed to demonstrate a likelihood of success and failed to provide a comprehensive description of the required elements.
Based on the review,
and the analysis of the petition, supporting documentation and the information gathered at the capacity interview, it is the county staff's determination that the petitioners are demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the proposed educational program.
The law identifies four indicators to determine if the petitioners are not able to successfully implement the instructional design stated in the petitions.
The review team considered the evidence and found that three out of the four indicators are present, as listed on the screen.
First, the petitioner is unfamiliar with the content of the petition or the requirements of law that would apply to the proposed charter.
For example,
The petitioners are unfamiliar with the requirements of law regarding services for EL students and regarding suspensions and expulsions.
Second, the petitioners lack the necessary background critical to the charter school's success.
For example, while the school intends to base its entire program around the International Baccalaureate or IB framework, none of the site team members has direct experience with IB.
Third, the petitioners have presented an unrealistic financial and operational plan for the proposed charter school.
For example, the school intends to begin operation this coming school year with an overly aggressive enrollment plan that represents 30% of the district's entire population spread across 10 grade levels.
Furthermore, the identified location does not have proper zoning or a certificate of occupancy.
Some specific deficiencies within finding five are as follows.
The proposed educational program lacks an adequate description of an instructional program for English learners and students with disabilities.
The petition lacks required metrics within the eight state priorities for their measurable pupil outcomes as required under LCFF regulation such as a goal for English learner access to English language development standards and an English learner reclassification rate.
Furthermore, the petition fails to provide differentiated outcomes for student subgroups as required by LCFF.
Element 10 includes lists of non-discretionary, suspendable, and expellable offenses that fail to include offenses mandated by law, such as brandishing a knife and sexual assault.
The elements identified as not reasonably comprehensive are critical and directly impact the school's ability to implement a sound educational program.
Changes to these elements would require significant material changes to the petition which are outside the scope of an appeal.
In summary, the Los Angeles County staff found that the petition failed to demonstrate a likelihood of success and failed to provide a comprehensive description of the required elements.
We're happy to answer any of your questions.
Okay, I think at this point we want to go to public comment, if there is any.
Yes, would the following speakers please line up at the podium?
Angela Deramos, Debu Rodriguez, Ogo Johnson, Ayifani Ezruran, John White, Janelle Rooley, Dr. Ago Idowu.
We'll just remind folks that public comment is limited to one minute per speaker and there'll be a little light that comes on as well as a reminder when you reach that point in time.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Thank you.
Hello I'm Sheila Whitley and I'm speaking for California Teachers Association.
CTA is strongly opposed to overturning the decisions of the local school district that are well reasoned and best understand the needs of the students in the local area.
CTA is also opposed to authorizer shopping in which a charter school submits virtually the same petition to multiple school boards or submits the same petition repeatedly to the same district hoping for a different result.
ECA is an egregious example of this behavior.
If the State Board of Education were to approve this charter petition it would be endorsing this troubling practice.
ECA has presented a deficient charter school petition with an unrealistic recruitment plan, budget, and educational program.
It has been rejected by multiple school districts and the county board numerous times.
The state board should support the practice of local control wherein districts develop priorities and plans with input from all stakeholders, including parents, students, teachers, and community members.
In conclusion, this appeal should be denied.
Time.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Debbie Rodriguez in support of Eagle Collegiate Academy.
Of Acton-Aquadulce district schools that they charter, 11 are virtual schools.
One is independent study.
Two are primarily classroom.
However, one of those is adult education.
One and only one school that they charter is site-based, offering high school students a high school diploma program specializing in academic credit recovery.
So basically the main choices for our children is traditional district boundary schools or virtual.
EGLE's unique academic program is like nothing offered in Acton-Acuadulce community or the Antelope Valley and Santa Clarita Valley communities.
This is why EGLE's support continues to be so strong and continues to grow.
Families in the Santa Clarita Valley, Antelope Valley, Castaic, Fraser Park, Fillmore, and San Fernando Valley are waiting to thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Dr. Ayodeji Idu.
I am a parent and resident of Kanye country.
I know that there are many families like me that are eagerly waiting for Igu College Academy to open.
The parents like the fact that IB requires that school leaders and teachers are trained so they know for sure that their children are being taught by trained teachers.
It's been a long journey to get here.
I've been to the site, and I've seen Dr. Johnson make numerous connections with the engineers.
And also, the last time we were here, there is a gentleman from IB from New York that answers all the questions.
So we appreciate and urge the board to approve Eagle Collegiate Academy.
Thank you.
I am Ifanyi Zuku, my five-year-old daughter, and my two little twins, boys, are very desirous to attend Eagle College Academy.
We all reside in Santa Clarita, and that's why I am here today.
However, I want to call your attention to
silent points that the Honorable Senator representing our district, the 21st District of the State Senate, sent to you.
I know you all have it, but please give me a few seconds to highlight certain areas that will make you approve the college.
He's in support of it.
As a state senator representing Santa Clarita Valley and surrounding communities, where students will be attending ECA reside.
I'm actually aware of the scarcity of education choice for our residents.
The city of Santa Clarita does not have any classroom-based charter for its residents.
It appears- Time.
Concerns of the CED- Time.
time.
I'm Elizabeth Chislett and I'm the IB coordinator and art teacher for Eagle Collegiate Academy.
I've been to IB informational sessions and webinars and I'm looking forward to getting the IB training for Eagle Collegiate Academy.
Thank you.
Good morning, Board President Darling-Hammond, board members.
My name is Janelle Rooley.
I'm an attorney with the Law Offices of Young, Mini, and Core.
We're here today in support of Eagle Collegiate Academy and seeking your yes vote today.
What you're hearing today is the sort of apex of families who are desperate for change in this particular area, for change and for choice in this area.
Families are willing to drive.
This is not a dense urban area.
Families are willing to drive in order to find a classroom-based charter school option that serves their students in the way that they're looking for, a K-12 SPAN school.
The location in Acton, the reason that the petitioners keep going back to Acton is because that's where the facility is, and charter law says that we have to petition the district where we're going to be located.
And so that's why they keep going back there.
In addition, it's also convenient for all of the families, or as convenient as possible for them to get there.
So the enrollment will come from outside of the district.
The concern that the budget relies on enrollment, I mean, I think that's true for every school, right?
The enrollment has to do with the budget.
Thank you very much.
I will close the public hearing and we'll begin discussion.
I'd like to ask Sue Burr.
We may come back to some of the previous speakers for questions as needed.
So maybe I would ask Lisa to come back up because I think that, as I mentioned in my clarifying questions, the bulk of the conversation at ACCS was about the issue of facilities.
And at least as I review the materials that came to us after the meeting, I'm not sure that it's resolved.
And so I'd like you to talk a little bit about your assessment of that.
And also especially about the use permit needing to be an E permit, because I know we have new members and I'm not sure that they know of that requirement.
So if you could just clarify that, I'd appreciate it.
Yes.
So our concerns are, I did go through everything that they submitted to us in terms of the leasing of the portables, which I think is reasonable.
Our concerns still lie in, they're going into an existing church building.
So in that church building, they think they can do four classrooms.
which is probably fine.
However, we don't know the accessibility.
If there's any accessibility issues at this church, that's one issue that I'm concerned about.
Also, even if it is zoned for school purposes, let's just say, there's a difference between the zoning and then what the building code standards then are.
So whether it's zoned appropriate for educational purposes, the permitting piece, the building code piece, it has to be an e-occupancy.
And so in order to be an e-occupancy and to meet those building code standards, there will be renovations within that building that will need to be made to be e-occupancy.
And that is a requirement of our MOU, of the state board's MOU with the charter schools.
and that does need to happen prior to opening.
So that, in essence, until our facilities folks can get in there, if this petition is approved, to see what's even involved, I don't see how that can get done within the next two to three months for this school to be able to open.
So we are really concerned about that.
Then if it doesn't open, then we're in a different situation.
So I would just say the majority of the folks on the ACCS, many of whom have had personal experience with this kind of activity of getting modulars in place and we're very skeptical that this could happen by the proposed opening date.
And I agree, I think, with what the department has said for sure about the aggressive enrollment projections.
To have 355 kids there in August, and there seems to be a little bit of a time discrepancy between when they would actually, even if they were able to dot all the I's and cross all the T's, get all the modulars in place, that couldn't happen until the end of September at the earliest is what I heard.
So, I'm happy to listen to other comments or I can make a motion now, but I don't know if other people have questions or comments.
I'm sorry.
Felisa, and then I see Ting, and then I'll come back to Patricia.
Thank you.
I think that if this was based on aspirational and a model that you would aspire to, this is definitely something that seems like a great option for students.
However, I'm very concerned about the feasibility of it.
And in particular, when it comes to enrollment, because we have 400 interested individuals, but we're also looking to open K-8, which is a huge grade span.
And so from these 400, and also the facilities.
So the facilities issues, I did my little time with facilities.
It's not only, we always find something as you're in that process.
And then try to remove a portable.
You will be surprised how expensive that is.
It's more expensive than putting the portable on the site.
Removing it actually is a lot more costly, and if you're leasing land from somebody, you wouldn't have the choice.
You would have to remove the portables.
Unlike what we did at schools, we just left them there, because it was just too expensive to actually
So with the 400 interests, do we have a sense of the breakdown?
So out of those 400, how many are interested in kinder, first, second, where are they coming from?
Because to populate a school K-8, we're not growing the school.
We're assuming that we'll have enough students for nine grades.
I just don't see that realistic.
I'll have the petitioner speak to that.
We just know how many they had, but I don't know the breakdown.
Okay, thank you.
Is it possible to bring up the PowerPoint because it was in the presentation?
I wanted to take you straight to the presentation so that you can visually see that as well.
So this is the breakdown that we submitted.
We had, oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
So this is in the presentation that we turned into you from the 417 parents that were interested, because some of them have multiple children.
And so this is what the breakdown we have.
So for pre-K, we had 73.
For TK, we had 12.
For K, we had 88.
For grade 1, we have 58, grade 2, 48, grade 3, 57, grade 4, 54, grade 5, 34, grade 6, 49, grade 7, 51, and grade 8, 36.
So you would start with about four kinder classes.
Walk me through how you would open your school.
These are the people who are showing interest.
But based on what we try, that's why we know we're confident that we're going to have to do a lottery, because we are only going to have 355 students.
And what we put in our petition is that we're going to have 20 to 1.
So we're only going to have two of each class, except for eighth grade, which would be just one classroom, one grade.
And you're also starting the IB program wall to wall.
So every single one of your grades would be your teachers go through the IB program, correct?
Yes, ma'am.
So I'm not sure if maybe the staff could tell us more about the person from IB.
I think his name is Philip Evans.
The letter that I read here is not really a letter of support, but rather a letter that describes the process to become IB.
So when this person came, was he
in support and saying they're ready to implement this model, or is it more about the model?
Because I think there's a difference.
He went into detail about how the model is rolled out and how they partner, but there was really nothing in the letter that said, I believe that EGLE Collegiate is ready and positioned to implement.
and he stated that when he was here the letter was more to help because unfortunately he couldn't make it today he really wanted to be and based on the questions that he was asked he wanted to make it clear that it is not necessary for IB teachers to be trained to implement IB PYP and IB MYP before starting and so he wanted to explain what the protocol was so that you guys will understand it and so in order to
do a wall-to-wall PYP and NYP, you're pretty much using your curriculum with their, you know, strategies, and they help you and train you throughout the process.
And that's what he wanted to explain, so that it's step-by-step.
Because it seemed to him, as he was listening, that that, you know, from the questions he was receiving, it wasn't clear what that meant.
Even though all those things are also in the petition, and we can go into the petition and see that.
I just want to say I think this is super ambitious.
I want to buy into it.
I've just seen both on the facility side, on the enrollment side, and I've also had experience enrolling out IB.
And to do it all concurrently just seems very ambitious to me.
But thank you.
Okay, thank you.
And I also just, for the petitioners, I appreciate your vision for the program and it sounds like there is a need for something different in that particular area.
But I'd also agree with member Ortiz-Lacombe that it is extremely ambitious and to start TK through eighth grade, wall to wall,
and to have fidelity and integrity to that model instead of growing it slowly so that you can really make sure that you have quality from the get go and grow that quality.
So I have some concerns.
My question is around I'm trying to get a little bit better understanding of the context of this district and the several non-site based
charter schools in there, because while I agree that the enrollment is unrealistic based on the small number of district students, there's reference that you'll be drawing from outside of the district.
I don't know how far away those other districts are, and also I don't, and what's the context of those other charter schools?
Would you be drawing students from those other charter schools, or are they?
Not necessarily, no, unless they choose to come to us.
We haven't had people from those independent charter schools that were involved.
We live in a community, in an area that's like 15 minutes from each other, these small, small communities right there, and so parents are used to driving to different areas.
There used to be a school there as well, where parents drove all the way from Santa Clarita and then Lancaster to come to school there.
So it's not,
You don't have to drive too far to get there.
In fact, the location of the property is really on the boundary.
It's actually a little bit closer to Santa Clarita than to the main Actinago Dulce location as well.
So it just so happens that it's right there and it's a very reasonable facility.
But the driving distance from one area to the other within that community is not that far.
So it's possible for all these parents, and they know that, and that's why they come from different areas.
Well, I have to say that I'm confused.
First of all, good morning, and thank you very much for being here today.
Let me congratulate you, first of all, for the innovation that you all have taken in your approach to trying to create this program.
An international baccalaureate program is probably one of the most difficult types of academic endeavors
that you could try to create for students.
The first time I learned about IB, I actually was jealous and wished I could be immediately reincarnated so I could have the chance to go back to school as a student and participate in a program like that.
So I think the work that you're trying to do falls greatly within the spirit of the charter school law about creating innovation, creating
unique educational opportunities for students.
So I'm not confused about that.
I'm actually confused as a member of this particular dais on this particular conversation because a lot of times when we get to this appeal level, I have actually heard my colleagues
talk about the importance of the innovation and the importance of creating these alternatives in these communities over all other matters concerning the problems that may have been identified about the development or creation of the school in the first place.
So I'm confused that I'm hearing prioritization of issues that previously have not always been the concern.
But that's my confusion.
What I'm not confused about is that your petition has been heard several times by a couple of different school districts and several times by the same county school board.
And it's been reviewed several times.
And there are commonalities of concerns that have been raised
in all of those hearings.
And so what I have clearly heard is the distinct impression that some of those issues have not been addressed.
So I'm going to identify the things that I've heard.
My colleagues are not going to give me the time to ask all the questions I want.
So I'm going to give you a choice after I list all the issues.
EL students, suspensions and expulsions, the IB program, your enrollment, your facilities, and this thing about the E permit.
So I'm setting aside suspension and expulsions.
That's about what's in the law and whether or not your petition adequately addresses that.
My colleague's only gonna let me ask you a couple of questions about one of those issues, because they don't have that kind of patience, and I appreciate that.
I'm just looking and saying, because I know they don't have enough.
So which one of those issues with now and I'm gonna tell you right now.
I have some really hard questions So which one of those issues would you like me to ask my questions about?
I think I want to address the facility issue because he was Talked about it seemed like at the Advisory Commission as meetings The idea of enrollment was a little bit resolved and even the IV was seemed like it was resolved Okay, but there's a difference between enrollment and facility.
So that's what I'm saying.
So I would like to I would like the facility one
Okay so I'm gonna start I'm gonna stick with the facilities issue because I agree I don't believe your petition clarifies exactly what you're being asked to address on the facilities issue.
So if I understand you correctly you're going to be in your plan is to have two classes of kindergarten through eighth grade students but you'll have one eighth grade class right?
Can you tell me how many rooms that means you need to have?
So, in the building itself.
No, no, that's not what I asked you.
Can you tell me how many rooms that means you need to have to have two classrooms in each grade level and one eighth grade class?
18?
Okay.
So those are just classrooms, correct?
Where's the cafeteria?
In the building.
Where are the bathrooms?
Where are the offices for the administration?
Is there a library?
Yes or no, is there a library?
Okay.
Are there any other supplementary or adjunct facilities for students for other types of activities like P.E.
or music or anything like that?
classrooms, you know, double portable classrooms, right?
So they come in 24 by 60, I believe, and they're double classrooms.
So even though it says 13, they're actually 10, and they're double.
So the one that the eighth grade students will be in, the way we design, and I have, you know, a little plan here that we're just using on our own.
So inside the building, the pre-K through
Third grade will accommodate in the building with the cafeteria and the hall and the offices and the restrooms as well.
And then outside the portables, there will be five double portables and four through eight will be there.
The additional one where the eighth graders will be is what we're calling the academic center.
Okay, so this gets then to the nut of the question about the timeline and the work that has to be done on the facilities.
I very clearly heard both from the county office, as well as from the district, and from our staff, and I actually pulled the tape and listened to some of the deliberations from the ACCS.
about the work that would be done.
So I think you may have delved into and answered this question.
You have clearly stated that there is work that would have to be done for the portables that you are going to receive in order for you to be able to house two classrooms in each of those buildings.
Let me finish my question.
So there's work that would need to be done in the church building you have in order for it to meet.
There's three different requirements you have to meet.
The zoning code
the permitting code requirements, as well as the building code requirements to house children in a school.
What are the current requirements just for the church building you have that need to be addressed to meet each of those three requirements?
So we went back, because in our conversations with the engineers and the regional planning engineers as well, they told us that we didn't need a conditional use permit.
So we went back and we get the letter.
I'm not interested in what they told you.
You need to be clear we're telling you what you have to get based on what you were told by our staff that you would have to get to be a state board authorized school.
What are the zoning, building code, and permitting requirements that you have to address in the church building itself today?
There will be no zoning because it's already zone C3 and that could be used for schools.
But you understand we require an E permit not a C. I know the two letters rhyme but there's a difference between a C and an E.
Well, the C is a commercial building.
So a commercial building could be used to make an e-occupancy.
So that's what the zoning verification letter is explaining.
And that's what we haven't really had conversation because facility was not something that the staff came up with.
The city staff usually isn't so we really have not had a sit-down Conversation with them to discuss what was happening It was just because that advisory commissioners brought it up and we started talking about that And so to make it a little bit more specific for you.
We went to get those things.
But yes the permit
is that if we needed a permit, then we would have to do a conditional use permit, which takes quite a bit.
But we don't need to do a conditional use permit in order to use a church as a school.
So it's your opinion that there's nothing else you would need to do to the church building itself in order to satisfy the board's requirement that you have an E permit.
Is that your opinion?
That's what the Los Angeles County Department of Regional Planning told us.
Let me be specific.
The Los Angeles County Office of Regional Planning is not here for me to ask them any questions.
I'm just asking you.
So I want to make sure I understand.
It's your opinion and it's your assertion today that your building is fine with the C permit you have and the E permit we're asking for, in your opinion, is a non-issue.
Is that correct?
Well, I think that staff would have to come and address that because there is no EAP from me.
It's okay.
I got you.
Okay.
All right.
I'm going to ask that we try to bring this to a point.
And then for the other buildings that are outside of the church.
You're going to be leasing those and there's some retrofitting requirements that have to be done.
Now, like Board Member Ortiz-Lacon, I've also had experience with getting portables on a campus and doing all the retrofitting requirements, particularly as it relates to accessibility issues.
You have in your budget a little over $275,000 for the modules and you identified something else that you're also setting aside in your budget.
For the number of portables and the amount of work that you're doing, I can tell you right now, that's not enough money.
the district that I worked in, which is now Twin Rivers, spent considerably more money on considerably fewer portables, particularly to do the retrofitting requirements for the accessibility issues.
What are you basing the dollar amounts that you have in your budget on for all of those portables?
because we're going to be leasing the portables, not buying them, and also because the class, the people, the organizations that sell classroom, modular class, I mean class, modular classrooms, they usually have to be e-ready by the state before they can sell it.
So those buildings come, they will certify that it's already E-ready, and all they have to do is just set it up.
And they actually, in the quote that we submitted to you guys, just so you can have an idea of what it looks like, it shows what it takes to set it up and how much it will cost to remove it.
And so that's for a 12-year project.
a 12-month lease.
And so it is within our budget, because our intention was always to lease it.
It was never something that we've had an opportunity to really have a good conversation with staff, because they never came up with that as a finding and didn't have questions about our facility.
OK.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate you letting me, and my colleagues also, for letting me do a deep dive on those pieces.
Thank you.
Thank you, ma'am.
Good morning.
Thank you for being here.
I want to commend you on the vision that you have.
It seems no doubt to me that in that district they need a school-based charter program for students to access and outside.
I have the privilege of opening three charter schools and
have the understanding of the facility requirements.
And what I'm concerned about is the facility, but also that you have a lot that you're riding on that is outside your control.
A lot of things have to fall in place by September 30th for students to get what they need based on the promises you're bringing to the table.
In addition to that, there are promises around the IB program.
And so my question is, the knowledge of the IB program is residing in the external provider at this point, correct?
You have one staff member that has spent some time learning about what the IB requirements are, but in terms of the knowledge of that and how it unfolds, it's in an external provider at this point.
because the teachers would have to be trained and IB doesn't require for the teachers to be already trained in order to implement IB, PYP, and MYP.
And the bulk of that training would come?
It will come during the summer.
We're going to have a two-day, 15-hour training that is a requirement that will come and do it face-to-face.
And then in our calendar, excuse me, bell schedule, we have days, hours built in on Wednesday through this.
I'm so sorry, where they have opportunity to meet and collaborate.
That is something that we really, really put a lot of emphasis in.
So we have built it into the schedule that every Wednesday, they'll have two hours in the afternoon from one, three hours from one to four to be able to continue to collaborate and learn and grow.
Well, I commend you.
And I think dreaming big is important.
And I think kids need options and opportunities.
At this point, I'm struggling with so much.
It's out of your control.
I just wanted to say one thing, though.
The, again, the county, thank you so much, the county regional planners, and I know it's not CDE, and since we haven't had that conversation with them, I don't know, other than what we're hearing today, what they think.
But the county regional planners, who are the ones who will certify us to meet CDE requirements, told us the building permit.
that they will finish this in two months or less because they're doing building permits.
They're familiar with the building.
We're not retrofitting the building.
We're gonna use the rooms as they are.
We're just gonna paint, do all those kinds of things and bring them up because he has those things in there already.
So we're not gonna knock anything down.
We can put a panel, but things like that.
And because of that, they believe that it could be done.
In fact, they said since we're at school, yeah, these are their words, and we have their cards, that they can even have their office managers bump us up to help us if that is necessary.
And so these are the conversations we've had.
And then they talked to the land engineering as well to confirm what needs to be done, the civil engineering team.
Comments or questions from members of the board?
Sue?
I'm sorry, Eileen?
Just a comment to the board, I've been actually to another school based charter out in Santa Clarita and actually a project based one that's actually been around for a long time and realized the need for classroom based charters versus the remote online and school resource centers.
Again I think the IB base and the philosophy and the community
The commitment to that philosophy and training is a strong one, in my opinion, and I believe you hear a community that would really like their own school.
My worry is we're in May, and those of us who've run schools and know what the issues are, I think the timeline's really short.
and parents saying interest in actually enrolling is one the actual is a little discrepant between those that are enrolling because if I was a parent of all those kindergarten kids 88 kids I would want to know I have a seat in case this one doesn't open and then so I don't know that even though they might be interested the reality of 155 kids coming the other thing is our experiences in growing charters and the ones that
is that they tend to grow, say, K-2, K-3, and then eventually grow.
So I feel like they're trying to go K-8 all at once.
And those of us who've led schools realize the philosophy in developing an early ed program, and then the early grades, and then the middle school is a whole different game.
And I just think there's a lot of staffing issues in a short amount of time to roll up.
So I guess I'm worried on the timing and also the phase-in process of it, but I certainly think the intention and the commitment I.B.
and the opportunity to provide parents with another option in the area is an important one.
I would just second those thoughts.
I think the commitment and the
Effort that's been put into it is really commendable.
There's clearly a need in that a region and so we have to consider the petition as it is, but it is Definitely appreciated both the vision and efforts that have been undertaken.
I
So I would just echo my colleagues comments and express my appreciation to the petitioners for your Vision for your desire to try to provide an opportunity in an area that seems to be underserved But I am afraid I am persuaded by the department that
well as our colleagues on the Advisory Commission for Charter Schools and I would therefore move the department's recommendation to deny the request to establish the Eagle Collegiate Academy under the oversight of the SBE for the reasons that they articulated.
To that motion?
Is there any other discussion of the motion?
Hearing no more discussion
All in favor, aye.
Any opposed?
Any abstentions?
Thank you.
10 or 15 minute break.
I think the second petition for the rest of the public hearing is actually delayed in the airport or maybe they've arrived.
Okay, great.
But we'll still take a 10 minute break because we need one.
Okay we're delighted that the folks who were stranded in Los Angeles have managed to get here but we are going to take item 18 next which is public comment because we have a public commenter on a particular time schedule so we're going to open public comment now.
So for public comment, we have two speakers, Rigel Massaro and Elizabeth Chislett, who may actually have been for the prior item.
OK.
We'll find out.
Rigel.
Board Chair and members, Rigel Massaro on behalf of Public Advocates.
We have some significant legal concerns about CDE's implementation of ESSA's requirement to report inequities in students' access to quality teachers.
Now in the LCAP addendum and forthcoming state report to the U.S.
Department of Education,
Contrary to the board-adopted ESSA plan definitions, CDE is treating provisional permit holders as credentialed teachers and thus is not including them in either the ineffective or out-of-field teacher designations.
This position contravenes the plan itself, its procedural history, and state certification law.
Under NCLB and state law, permit holders have never been highly qualified or fully certified.
The board intended to align ESSA with priority one under LCFF and therefore originally defined ineffective as either misassigned or those serving without a full credential.
Ultimately, full was deleted so that in addition to preliminary and clear credentials, intern credentials would also be considered effective.
Permit holders were never defined effective by the board.
CDE's confusion will grossly distort the real distribution of underprepared and ineffective teachers in schools serving low income and students of color.
Thank you.
Public advocates.
And do we have another commenter?
I think they might have been for the last item.
They signed up with Eagle Collegiate as their affiliated organization.
Elizabeth was at the podium at one point, so I think we're done.
Item on the establishment, the request for reauthorization of International Charter School, and I'm gonna start with Lisa.
Okay, item number 16 is for Los Angeles International Charter High School, and this is a renewal petition, but it is for establishment as a school under the authorization of the state board.
Excuse me.
On January 22, 2019, the Los Angeles County Board of Education denied the Los Angeles International Charter High School renewal petition by a vote of 5 to 1.
The petitioners then submitted a renewal petition to the State Board on January 28, 2019.
The California Department of Education recommendation is that the State Board hold a public hearing to deny the request to renew L.A.
High School International, a 9th through grade 12 charter school, under the oversight of the State Board of Education.
The recommendation is based on that the petitioner does not meet the renewal criteria as they do not perform overall, at least equal to its comparable district schools where the majority of the pupils would otherwise attend.
And additionally, the petition does not provide a reasonably comprehensive description of eight of the 15 required charter elements.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools met on April 10, 2019.
The Advisory Commission moved staff recommendation to deny the petition to the state board.
The motion did not pass by a vote of 4 to 4.
Five votes are required to move an Advisory Commission motion forward to the board and a recommendation.
Therefore, no recommendation was moved.
A little bit of background on the school.
They have been operating since 2005.
They're currently serving 153 pupils in grades nine through grades 12.
They're located within the geographic boundaries of the LA Unified School District.
The petitioner, as part of their renewal package, is also proposing to add grade six through grade eight, an independent study program, and to change the name of the school to LA International Charter School.
Their mission is to provide pupil achievement by providing a high, to improve pupil achievement, excuse me, by providing a high quality standards-based educational program for all pupils that attend.
They focus on college preparatory program, college readiness for all its pupils, and a personalized learning environment.
As I mentioned, if renewed, the petition is proposing to add grade 6 and increase to 172 pupils in grade 6 and grade 9 through grade 12 in the first year, which would be 19-19-19-20, and then increase to serve 240 pupils in grade 6 through grade 12, so then adding on the 7th and 8th grade as well by the end of the five-year term in 2023-24.
Now in terms of renewal criteria for the establishment, we talked about the education code that determines how we look at establishments as new schools.
This is the criteria that is set forth for renewal.
So education code 47607 sets forth that criteria.
The authority that granted the charter shall consider increases in pupil academic achievement for all groups of pupils served by the charter school as the most important factor determining whether to grant a charter renewal.
The entity that granted the charter determines that the academic performance of the charter school is at least equal to the academic performance of the public schools that the charter school pupils would otherwise have been required to attend and the academic performance of the schools in the school district in which the charter school is located, taking into account the composition of the pupil population that has served at the charter school.
So we'll talk a little bit more about this, but this is where our comparison schools come into play.
And then also as we select those comparison schools, the demographics of those schools as well to meet this area of the education code.
The renewal criteria under 52052 talks about alternative measures.
Three parts of this education code still refer to the academic performance indicator, the API, as you all know, hasn't been calculated since 2013-14.
There still is one provision of the education code that, in F, that provides for the following in determining whether a charter is meeting legislative or programmatic requirements.
It states the alternative measures that show increases in pupil academic performance for all groups of pupils school-wide and among numerically significant pupils shall be used.
And for CDE we use CASP data and which is then reflected also in the dashboard as the alternative measure criteria for purposes of renewal.
For the comparison school that CDE did, we selected seven schools where the pupils would have otherwise been required to attend, selected these schools within a five-mile radius of the current high school, schools that were similar enrollment for Hispanic Latinos, special ed, English learners, and pupils with disabilities.
In the following two tables, we have the first chart is the percent of pupils that met or exceeded on the 2015-16 through 2017-18 CASP assessments for ELA and math for the school and the CDE comparable schools.
And then the second chart is the demographic data that we talked about just a moment ago for the LA International School and then the CDE comparable schools.
The data shows that the decreases in ELA and significant decreases in math results in 2016-17 and 17-18, and that LA International does not perform overall at least comparable to the district schools.
So this is the first chart.
You all have the presentation in your inboxes.
I know this is a little small, but if you want to refer to it there.
So LA International High School is here at the top.
And then the schools that CDE used in terms of comparable schools are listed here as well.
The two asterisk are ones that LACO also used in their comparison schools as well.
And then the second chart is the demographic information and to just break down that information so you can see why we selected these schools.
Now in terms of the dashboard and the summary report, so Cindy is here because I'm still learning this language.
So she is here in case we have any questions about the dashboard.
But the 2017 California School Dashboard Summary Report is listed here.
Since in 2017 it did not include, the dashboard didn't include the academic indicators for ELA and math.
You won't see that here.
But they also didn't submit information for the local indicators in 2017.
So as we go further into the 2017 dashboard indicator report, they are green here in graduation rate and yellow in suspension rate.
And then we go to the 2018 California School Dashboard Summary Report.
So this is the first year of the academic indicator for high school.
So ELA and math here does have a color, yellow for ELA, red for math.
And then the suspension rate did come down to red.
And the graduation rate, still green, and college career.
So looking further into this, ELA, here's the yellow.
They are 15.4 points below standard.
But for mathematics is the most concerning being in red and 131.7 points below standard here on the dashboard.
Graduation rate being in green, and then the suspension rate came down to red.
So this is the breakdown for ELA.
And then, I'm sorry, by student subgroup, by all student subgroups, and then student subgroups by performance level.
So yellow in Hispanic and socioeconomically disadvantaged.
And then for math for 2018, for all student subgroups being in red, orange for the socioeconomically disadvantaged, and here more detailed information on each of the subgroups.
So in LACO's review of the renewal criteria, they did complete a review of 2015-16 through 2017-18 CASP assessment data as well for not only district comparable schools, but they also did a look at resident schools.
They found declines in English and ELA and math school-wide and for all pupil groups.
And they determined that they had not demonstrated increases in pupil academic performance for all groups of pupils served by the school.
They went on to determine they do not qualify for renewal criteria as its academic performance is not at least equal to the academic performance of the public schools that the pupils would otherwise have been required to attend.
So this first chart is of the county chosen resident schools.
And so they have two charts.
They did one on resident schools and then one on comparable schools.
This is the first chart here of the resident schools and the second chart is of the comparison schools.
CDE's review of the LACO finding, CDE determined that LACO's review and analysis of the pupil academic data pursuant to the Ed Code was comprehensive.
They did consider increases in pupil academic performance for all groups of people served by the school as the most important factor in determining whether to grant renewal.
And the school itself, in the review of their renewal criteria, they compared their own CASP data for 15-16 through 17-18.
The data reflected a decline in academic performance in 2016-17 and a small increase in 17-18.
And they do acknowledge the challenge the school is experiencing with academic performance of pupils in mathematics.
And they are committed to continual improvement through comprehensive ongoing professional development for all their staff.
CDE notes that in the school's response to LACO's findings, they stated that LACO instructed them to use the same resident and comparison schools in their charter renewal, despite their objections that the list of the schools were flawed.
And this is coming from what the petitioner has stated.
They included a table of resident and comparison schools that the petitioner states are more accurate representation of the schools and reflect the increases.
The petitioner stated that they did not include these tables in the renewal petition because they were directed by LACO to stick with their schools that they had chosen.
In terms of alternative measures, the school does not meet the renewal criteria under 47607.
We did review the additional alternative measures information provided by the school.
The data reflects increases in 17-18 results in ELA and math for all pupils when compared to 16-17 only, so only for one year of comparison.
However, the data they presented for AP passage rates, they submitted some information for college acceptance rates, enrollment and honors in AP, that information relies on assessments for which we do not have independent confirmation of their reliability, validity, fairness, and alignment.
So we are not able to make an assessment on that information that was submitted to us.
We do note that LACO did not consider academic performance under the alternative measures criteria.
Their assessment was done on 47607, which is the initial renewal criteria, whether academic performance being the most highest standard.
So they just didn't look at alternative measures.
Also, in terms of the petition itself, we do have concerns about several of the elements that are lacking in the charter petition.
The petition does not overall present a reasonably comprehensive description of the educational program.
They are proposing to add grade levels, which is the grades six through eight, as I mentioned, and also independent study.
So with the current CASP scores at the high school level, we are concerned the petitioner wants to add additional grade levels as well, as well as an additional independent study program.
So we are concerned about that.
In terms of serving English learners, the petition does not include several areas that we typically see in a petition, a plan for serving ELs, description of the program.
They include a master plan, but the plan appears to be outdated and doesn't cite the correct statewide assessments that we would typically see.
Integrated and designated English language development is not included and there's not enough of a description about reclassification as well.
So there's some pieces really lacking in the petition that if it was renewed, we would really have to work with the school to better identify.
In terms of their ability to implement fiscally, they are fiscally viable.
Their projected budget is viable.
They do have positive ending fund balances and they do have plenty of reserves as well.
So as I mentioned, there are several of the charter elements that the petition does not include.
Eight of the 15 are not reasonably comprehensive.
The most material ones I've listed here in this slide, measurable pupil outcomes, method for measuring pupil progress, employee qualification, admissions requirements, and then suspension and expulsion procedures are the most material ones that we are concerned about.
In terms of measurable pupil outcomes, the petition outlines the baseline performance level, annual goals, et cetera, but they're not in alignment with the eight state priorities, and the tables do not include the pupil outcomes for all pupils for each subgroup.
Also in terms of the method for measuring pupil progress, we don't have the assessment tools lined out.
They don't describe how they will utilize a variety of these tools.
And then they don't outline a plan for collecting, analyzing, and reporting pupil data.
In terms of employee qualifications, they don't identify, the petition does not identify key positions in each categories, additional qualifications expected of these individuals, and then indicate the teachers and curriculum specialists, such as EL coordinators, how they will obtain the special ed certification or the EL authorization.
We do also have a concern about the admission requirements.
currently lay out a mandatory enrollment meeting for families.
And this seems to mandate parental involvement.
So we are concerned that that violates the education code as it would limit the school from admitting all pupils who would wish to attend.
And it also incorrectly lists some admission exemptions as well.
And then in terms of suspension of expulsion, they do not state that no people shall be involuntarily removed from the school for any reason unless a parent or guardian has been provided written notification to remove the student.
And they do not state that they will provide a hearing adjudicating by a neutral officer as well.
So there are some real specific pieces here from the education code that are lacking in the petition.
In summary, CDE staff is recommending denial.
The petition is not consistent with sound educational practice.
It does not perform overall at least equal to its comparable district schools where the majority of the pupils would otherwise attend.
And the petition does not provide a reasonably comprehensive description of the eight of the 15 required charter elements.
So this concludes my presentation.
If there's any questions I can answer at this time.
Just a couple of clarifying questions.
Again, thank you, Lisa, for your comprehensive presentation.
On the alternative measures one, if you could just pull that up for a second.
We've talked about this before, and I will just express my frustration again publicly about the statute being so outdated, referring to a measure or metric that we haven't used for five years or longer.
But what I'm a little bit concerned about here is just the comment about the data presented about AP passage rates and enrollment in AP relies on assessments for which we lack independent confirmation.
I'm a little concerned about that because we've approved AP as part of our college and career readiness indicator.
So I think to the extent we have independently validated it or Cindy and her staff have,
I would just be careful about that.
And I would suggest that that is an appropriate alternative measure.
So I just wanted to point that out.
And anything else that's in the CCI that we have approved, especially for a high school, a school that's, I think we need to make sure that we are looking at that and that is a legitimate piece of data or pieces of data to include.
Then the other just clarification question is on the suspension and expulsion.
And I think I've heard this in other petitions where there's statutory requirements.
Do we require petitioners to restate those statutory requirements or we acknowledge that they are, they have to abide by them?
was signed a couple of years ago that require a charter petition to outline the type of due process and what elements they'll suspend a kid for.
So that was a couple of years ago Governor Brown signed some legislation.
And we realize that some of that is still catching up.
We've had the conversation with other petitioners or other petitions about that.
So that part we realize is still, that law is still catching up in some of the petitions, but it is still a concern that it has been over a year and that hasn't been changed in this petition, so.
Lisa?
I want to echo the point of the APs made by Board Member Burr since we are including it in the CCI.
However, if I remember correctly, one of the issues with this particular proposal was that the students who pass the AP Spanish, the school does not teach AP Spanish.
So they couldn't attribute the passage rate to the school.
Is that correct?
I don't know that offhand.
I will have to look into that.
I believe it's deep into the charter, but that's one thing that I noted that though some students, the passage rate included AP Spanish, the school itself did not teach or provide an AP Spanish course.
So in that case, I do think that we need to give it a second look.
Okay.
Thank you.
Clarifying questions right now for Lisa.
Okay, so we're now gonna hear from the petitioner.
Yes.
I open public hearing and we will hear first from the petitioner.
So the petitioner will have 10 minutes and then that will be followed by the district and the county, well the county in this case.
If the county, if they're still here, they will have 10 minutes.
That will be followed by general public comment for one minute.
Oh.
We thought we had it, but Stephanie's grabbing it from her drive.
It should be just a moment.
No pressure.
Are we frozen?
All right, keep us posted.
you
All right, here we go.
We will now hear from the petitioner.
You have 10 minutes.
All right, thank you.
Good morning and thank you for having us.
as they expressed that our mission is that we produce leaders in our community, in our school, and that they are college ready and that they are ready for life beyond college.
I just want to share a little bit of history very quickly.
I've been at the school for less than three years, and that was due to a turnover of administration and teachers in 2016.
There was also a death.
where our students witnessed one of our students being hit by an 18-wheeler, and that was very impactful.
So you did see a drop and a decline in everything that happened at that school in 2016.
They called me and asked me if I could come and help and get them back on track and just renew the values and the core and the culture that this school was founded on.
And that's what I came to do.
And since we got through that hurdle, you will see that we have been increasing.
We haven't declined in our scores.
We've been increasing in our scores.
And I'm going to show you how.
Angie, will you say your name?
Angie Sims.
Sorry about that.
And I'm the executive director.
So historically, you would see an increase in scores from 2014-15.
We dropped in 2016 when we had that tragedy.
And then 2017-18, you'll see that we increased again.
But we increased in all of our subgroups.
We did have our students to take the AP Spanish, and we do offer AP Spanish, but it is a choice class, so if they choose to sign up for it, they can take it, but we do not prevent any student from taking any AP test that they wish to take because it betters them for college.
And that was a recommendation from Mr. Brown at LACO.
So I wanted to just have you guys look at the CASP scores because we had Charter Impact to pull up the demographics at our school and find out where would the bulk of our students come from, and this is why we disputed their original chart.
50% of our students would otherwise be at Woodrow Wilson, and 27% would be at Franklin.
If you look at Woodrow Wilson, we outperformed them in English, but they outperformed us in math.
If you look at the other schools that are in green, we outperformed them across the board, and those are also schools that our students would otherwise attend.
So you see that there are about five.
If you also look at the data, you will see that the only school on CDE's comparison chart that is making increases every year is Leches and Academia Advance.
Every other school, even that is outperforming us, is declining some up to 14 points per year.
So if you look at this chart, you'll see that Franklin, where 27% of students would go, they're dropping every year.
Woodrow Wilson is dropping every year.
So I ask, how could those schools be better serving our students than we are if we found where the problem was, if we got over our hurdle, and if we were making increases based on LACoE's recommendations, which were to implement intervention classes, we have math and English, which were also to implement an alternative way of data and testing, which is Illuminate, which is aligned to SBAC and California Common
scores a California Common Standards.
We did send you a copy of our SBAC related information through the Illuminate data and you could see there that our students are actually mastering those standards.
If you look at the graduation rate, we are 95% and there is only one school that is beating us.
We recognize that math is our weakest link.
And so based on those recommendations, we implemented the CPM courses.
and the students are starting to excel in math.
They are passing those standards.
If you look at the Illuminate data, we can't manipulate that.
That is a program where the students go on, they do the assessments, and they submit us back the percentage of students that are outscoring, outperforming in those categories.
So, if you look at what we sent you, there was initial mastery on the Benchmark 1 in Illuminate of 31%, and then 68% on Benchmark 2, 54% total mastery, but in 2018, and then in 2017, there was a 43%.
So, you see that it upped, the mastery upped.
Also, in the honors class, you'll see that we have upped our mastery from starting at 78% at the first benchmark to 85%, which was a 2% increase from 2017.
ELA is not our weakest area, but we do understand that there are some deficiencies, so we put together an English intervention class with reading intervention, and our students are leveling up by two grade levels in one school year.
And if you look also at that data, they are also mastering in their final exam, they're at a 98%.
for the Common Core Standards.
The retention and fluctuation, in 2016, two students enrolled after the start date.
In 2017-18, four of the 11th grade students enrolled after the start date and were tested, and six were tested after the start date as 10th graders.
So as you see, each year, as we're testing students, and even now this year, we have 11 new 11th graders.
that enrolled.
And when we're getting kids that are enrolling in March, or kids that are enrolling in February, or at the beginning of a school year, we're actually being looked upon, their test scores is what the previous school produced, not our school, because we have not had them long enough to educate them and prepare them.
You can't do it in less than a year.
And the reason why that's happening is because the demographics has changed.
These students are being removed from their home schools for behavior infractions, and that's why you saw our suspension rate grow up.
But our expulsion rate does not.
We do not kick them out.
We put them in programs and we help them.
We have a good percentage of our students now that are enrolling have been on house arrest.
They're on probation.
And some will tell you, some that are here now will tell you, this is the first time they've ever been on honor roll.
are felt proud of their academic experience here at our school.
We do have a five-year plan.
We implemented the intervention classes, the CPM math, we do ESPEC, AP, SAT, ACT exam support, we do Saturday school now, we do two practice exams and you'll see that
This even started as early as last year.
And again, I've just been there since the mid-year of 2016.
So, we have EL support for our students.
It is in our petition that they, after two years of classification, that we still monitor them, continue practice.
We do track the Illuminate desk data.
The teachers are trained on how to disaggregate data, but the students also are able to track their own data.
In many of their classes, they have their own folders and they're able to track their progress.
They have their own logins as well, so they're able to see when they're meeting their standards and when they're not.
They meet with their academic advisor at least once per quarter, but as needed because there are students on IEPs or 504 plans or have some behavior issues and they need more time.
So, we also have two practices and procedures.
So, on the school side, we are ensuring that students are prepared for college and success.
We're ensuring that all of the money and resources are well-stored.
They go right into our programs.
We ensure the organization is run by leaders that implement a positive culture.
We ensure the terms of the charter contract are fulfilled.
We ensure the organization meets the mission.
and that the goals are clear and the programs are supported, evaluated, and that we are being held accountable.
We are ensuring that the charter is operating legally and ethically.
We are ensuring that the CPSA and the LCAP meet the needs of continuous improvement.
The Board of Directors are ensuring to recruit and train its team in the capacity to govern
The Board of Directors adopts and maintains proper governing policies and practices.
The Board of Director policies and practices adheres to the Charter's mission.
And the Board of Directors ensures to monitor Charter's policies, procedures, and practices with fidelity.
I just want to leave you with a word from our students.
I've attended LACHS since my freshman year, and I'm currently a senior.
LACHS has been such an amazing school, and what I love about LACHS is how the teachers here are not just only educators, they're also life changers.
I had assistance with my five-year plan after high school, and with that, I'll be joining the U.S.
Navy.
I've also been a student of the month for the Lakers, and I'm in the running for a valedictorian.
I came to this school for recommendation from my cousin.
And coming here, I learned that this school is all about giving chances.
I went to Eaglewood High School, and I transferred because my brother had gotten enrolled to this school, LAICHS.
And he had got a home visit from the director and the counselor.
And when they were explaining how the school works, I had to make a decision.
And I only been here for a month.
And I like it.
I picked up all my grades.
It's getting better.
All my courses, they're getting made up.
My GPA is getting higher.
Then I'm going to start playing basketball next year.
I'm going to stay here again.
I want this school to stay open because it helped me a lot.
Hello, my name is Fisher Brown.
Some of the fears I have had.
Thank you.
And now we'll hear from LA County for 10 minutes.
Thank you President Hammond and board members.
My name is Indra Lopez-Ciccarelli and I am the Director of the Charter School Office at the Los Angeles County Office of Education or LACO.
After a thorough review, the LACO review team established that Los Angeles International Charter High School or LAI has not met the minimum academic criteria to be considered for renewal.
The petition presents an unsound educational program, the petitioners are demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the program, and the petition does not contain a reasonably comprehensive description of all required elements.
Any of these findings constitute legal grounds for denial.
For renewal, a charter school must demonstrate that it has met one of the academic performance criteria listed on the screen and specified in statute.
Only subsection number four highlighted on the screen applies to LAI.
To create a list of the public schools LAI students would otherwise have attended, LACoE uses data directly provided by the school.
At the time of testing in 2018, LAI had five resident schools that comprised 89.7% of LAI's enrolled students.
All other resident schools were only represented by one or two students at LAI.
To create a list of similar schools of the district in which the charter is located, LACOE staff begins with a list generated by edresults.org and then works with the school to come to an agreed upon list.
Schools are provided an opportunity to add or change the list if they provide a rationale.
The email on the screen from our office to LAI provides the school with this information.
LAI's response to LACO staff findings grossly misrepresents the LACO staff report in multiple areas, including academic performance, comparisons to resident and comparable schools, and deficiencies within the petition elements.
CASP ELA results show that the school-wide percentage of students at LAI that have met or exceeded standards has declined since 2016.
In 2018, LAI was outperformed by six of nine comparison schools in English language arts.
The two numerically significant subgroups at LAI, Hispanic students and socioeconomically disadvantaged students, both showed declines since 2016.
And for both of these subgroups, LAI was outperformed by five of nine comparison schools in 2018.
Similarly, CASP math achievement has declined since 2016, resulting in LAI being outperformed by eight of nine comparison schools for math in 2018, for all students and for all numerically significant student groups.
LAI's academic performance is not at least equal to its comparison schools.
Therefore, the minimum criteria for renewal has not been met.
In addition to analyzing the minimum academic performance criteria for renewal, the county board considered increases in pupil academic achievement for all groups of pupils served by the charter school as the most important factor in determining whether to grant a charter renewal.
LAI demonstrated an overall decrease in pupil academic achievement for all groups of pupils served by the charter school when measured over the last four years of the charter term.
Looking at the four-year comparison between 2015 and 2018, the overall percentage of students meeting or exceeding standards in English language arts dropped from 78% to 49%.
For the socioeconomically disadvantaged student subgroup, the percentage decreased from 77% to 50%, and for the Hispanic student subgroup, the percentage decreased from 78% to 48%.
In math, the overall percentage of students meeting or exceeding standards over this four-year period also decreased from 34% to 9%.
The socioeconomically disadvantaged student subgroup, the percentage decreased from 34% to 9% and the percentage of Hispanic students meeting or exceeding standards between 2015 and 2018 decreased from 35% to 7%.
These decreases in academic achievement for all groups of pupils served are required to be the most important factor when determining whether to grant the charter renewal.
Additionally, as noted earlier, LAI does not meet the minimum academic criteria to even be considered for renewal as they did not perform at least equal to its comparison schools.
Next, the review team determined that the renewal petition prevents an unsound educational program.
Per the California Code of Regulations, an educational program is to be considered unsound if any one of three criteria exist.
The review team determined that there is evidence for all three.
The first criteria of an unsound program is a program that involves activities that would present the likelihood of physical, educational, or psychological harm to the affected pupils.
The review team found that in 2016 and 2017, LAI had a suspension rate of over four times that of LA Unified, and in 2018, that increased to over 11 times the district rate.
Instead of articulating a plan to address the issue, the current petition increases suspension rate goal from 3% to 6%, which is still three times higher than the average rate for all schools in LA County in 2018.
The review team also found that the current student parent handbook lists 12 absences or tardies as grounds for expulsion, which is not aligned with either the petition or with current law.
The second criteria of an unsound program is a program not to be likely of educational benefit to the pupils who attend.
The review team performed a statistical analysis of all enrolled students and found that in 2017-18 at least 51% of LAI students would have otherwise attended a school with higher English language arts performance and at least 86.5% of LAI students would have otherwise attended a school with higher math performance.
also found was that the English learners at LAI are not receiving the designated ELD instruction and monitoring required by current law.
The third criteria of an unsound program is if the petition is for renewal, either the charter school has not met the standards for renewal or the charter school has not met the measurable pupil outcomes as described in its charter.
The review team found that both of these are true.
The school has not met the standards for renewal as previously discussed and an analysis of the measurable pupil outcomes in the current petition resulted in a determination that 17 of 20 MPOs were not met.
After reviewing the LAI record of past performance in the areas of academic achievement, governance, facilities, fiscal, and business operations, as well as responses from an extensive capacity interview, it was determined by the review team that the petitioners are demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the proposed program.
Some of the factors considered in this finding included three years of declining college and career readiness preparedness according to the California school dashboard, such that only 25% of the class of 2018 met the standard.
Standards not met for all five local indicators of the dashboard in both 2017 and 2018.
Declining enrollment each and every year of the charter term from a high of 271 in 2014 to just 140 last month.
A suspension rate that has increased from 0% in 2015 to 9.4% in 2018.
all new board members since the previous charter term when enrollment was at its peak and a board and an administration not familiar with nor compliant with both the MOU between LAI and LACO as well as requirements of law that apply to the charter school.
The review team found that 8 of 15 element descriptions are not reasonably comprehensive, 4 are reasonably comprehensive, and 3 are reasonably comprehensive with specific deficiencies.
The 8 elements found not reasonably comprehensive contain substandard descriptions, outdated language, and failures to meet legal mandates.
Responses to these findings by LAI, such as every EL student receives at least 20 minutes per week of designated pull-out EL instruction, further emphasize the school's lack of understanding with regards to current legal requirements.
Though charter schools are meant to be autonomous, LACO staff has worked hard to give feedback and resources to the school.
Many issues that are in our report such as low enrollment, EL concerns, compliance issues, and lack of rigor have been communicated several times and as far back as 2016.
LACO CSO was not the only entity to recognize a need to increase academic rigor.
The school's WASC visiting committee report from 2017 noted the number one school-wide critical area for follow-up as increased rigor in the classroom.
The significant drop in CAS performance was shared directly with current leadership in June of 2017.
And last year we again shared our concern about low academic performance on CASP as well as other concerns as shown.
Every year the school was asked to create an action plan to address these issues.
Many of the plans failed to address all unmet outcomes and implemented actions were not executed in a comprehensive manner in order to address underlying issues such as rigor.
When the county board last approved the LAI charter in 2014, the school was in its fifth year of enrollment growth and academic success as a high-performing school with college-bound students.
Since the renewal, LAI has experienced five years of enrollment and academic decline.
Despite any changes to the facility noted by the petitioner, the actual capacity of the location has increased over the charter term from 432 in 2016 to 460 currently.
Even though maximum occupancy increased, by 2017 enrollment had dropped to levels lower than 2009 and this year it is lower still.
Academics has similarly declined.
The most recent increase in ELA scores for 2018 over 2017 have not even brought the scores back to the 2016 levels, let alone to the levels achieved in 2014.
And math scores have remained at an all-time low.
Fewer than 1 in 10 students met the standard in math for the past two years.
In conclusion, the review team established that LAI has not met the minimum academic criteria to be considered for renewal.
Thank you.
We're going to take public comment at this time.
Are we ready for public comment?
We have 20 speakers signed up for public comment.
Sheila Whitley, Mike Bassler, Damian Moreno, Samuel Restrepo, Don Breaux, Darlene Hernandez, Claudia Perez, Angel Meza, Magdalena Resendiz, Zimri Garcia, Araceli Torres, Rafael Galdames, Joshua Angel, Gianna Garcia, Samuel Giochi, Jacque Franklin,
Nalini Pineda, Joanna Rodriguez, Valerie Rodriguez, and Nicole Rodriguez.
Please line up.
And we'll just ask you to be aware that it's one minute per speaker.
You'll have a little light go off.
And a reminder, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm Angela DeRamos on behalf of California Teachers Association.
I'm actually a fourth, fifth, and sixth grade intervention teacher in my other life, and so I know about interventions, and when we try, when things are not working, we do something different.
The whole point of a charter is to do something new and improved, and what we don't have is improved, we don't have the same, we have significant decline.
If my students suddenly had a significant decline over a year or two I would not do the same.
I would do something different.
In that light we urge you to deny this renewal.
Thank you.
Greetings board.
Dr. Michael Baisley.
LACOE is leaving out a lot of information in which they have data for.
Enrollment dropped because the landlord rewrote the lease and removed five acres of land and the capacity to enroll more students.
Thus, LHS has received Prop 39 from LAUSD to have space on their campus.
Please understand all that you've heard was not true.
and LACO has the information.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Damian Moreno.
I am the visual arts teacher at the high school.
What I'd like to say is that we do have a community-based school.
Our students know each other, they know the staff, and we are a very caring and loving community.
There are a lot of things that aren't measurable, that aren't on the statistics.
Some of the kids that we work with have a lot of anxiety issues and other things that are life goals that we try to help them achieve.
So it's not just about the scores for me at least.
Yes, it's important, but there is a lot more to a student's life that is important.
Other than that, I would like to say that there are a lot of students in our schools that would be lost in the bigger community.
And the fact that we have those students in our schools helps them out.
We have students that have, like I said, anxiety.
There's LGBT students that we are very fortunate to have at our school.
And that population that would be lost in other schools, like I said, they help each other out.
They're helping the other students become more accepting of people that are different than them as well.
Other than that, I would just like to say that I hope that we could get renewed.
Thank you.
Good morning board members, my name is Samuel Estrepo.
I'm a chemistry teacher at Laches.
This is the first year that I've had a school with a facility to actually supply the materials that I need to actually even teach an AP chemistry class, which isn't being taught, but I have all the materials possible in order to be able to do that.
That's one of the first schools that I've ever been teaching for 12 years.
And I actually followed Ms.
Sims from where we used to teach at together as both teachers until she became director.
And I followed her because I believed in her.
I saw her strength in her teaching capabilities.
I saw her strength in her relationship buildings with the students.
I saw her strength in willing to fight.
I think you see that in her, and I hope that that takes your decision making rolling forward with the momentum that we do have in order to renew our charter.
Thank you, guys.
Good morning, my name is Ron Breaux.
I've worked at small county schools, large unified schools, and public charter schools.
I came on to this public charter school with Ms.
Sims a couple years ago, and while we're not perfect, we have an infrastructure in place that will help to improve our culture, improve our test scores, and our community.
We have a group of staff that are in place that are willing to work with our staff and work with our students to build up these scores if we're given a chance.
We also have a community of students that are in need of us who are willing and able and have the structure to work with them.
But we need to have the ability to work with these students.
Some of these students would be, I don't know where since they've come from other places, sent away from other places or just wander from other places.
But they come to us where they are and we meet them where they are.
So I build them to where they can be.
But we just need the chance to put this infrastructure and these things we have in place to build our community through our family atmosphere that we have at our school.
And we just need that chance.
Thank you.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Angel Meza.
This is our daughter's first year at Leach's.
And we want to let you know that this is the only school that we have available in the neighborhood.
We need a place where the kids can actually excel.
My daughter came with low grades and she is now current or above the level that she needs to be.
I need you guys to know that in the amount of time that Miss Simms has been at the school, going from the disastrous level that she took the school at, she's actually
made it grow, made it bloom.
A lot of the students have no place else to go.
And I think Ms.
Simms deserves the chance.
She deserves this charter to be renewed.
And if you give her that chance, she'll show you that she is a champion, she's a warrior, and she'll turn the school around.
Thank you.
Hi, good morning.
My name is Darlene Hernandez, and I'm the college and career counselor.
In my two years, I have seen an influx of students enrolling as 10th and 11th graders, as special education students, as students that were failing and are in fear that they would not graduate.
Many of them enrolling as late as the last two to three months of school.
This week alone, we welcome an 11th and 12th grade student.
We now also have two students that are in foster youth.
Here at Leches, and as students share all the time, we are a second chance school.
We are the home for six students on academic probation and or house arrest, but are now coming to school daily and are even placing honor roll for the first time in their academic career.
We are an institution of hope and even when with the struggles of the SBAC performance, it cannot be denied that we are graduating and sending our students to college.
If approved by the state, we promise that Latres will make you proud.
I'm from the community of Highland Park.
I went to Franklin High School.
Comparing a public school to a charter, you know the difference?
Thank you.
Good morning board members my name is Claudia Perez I am the current board president.
LACL's findings state that we have an unsound educational program based on our independent studies program and middle school program yet the independent study and the middle school programs are both material revisions.
They have made determinations based on the programs that have yet to be implemented.
We hope you will ask clarifying questions as LACL has reported information that is untrue.
I'm a parent there.
I have a child who is autistic and is excelling.
He's taking his AP exam this week.
I'm also an alumni parent.
My daughter graduated in 2014 and the situation where the school was at that time compared to how it is now is such a difference.
There's so many more opportunities.
There's so many more classes.
It gives them the ability to go and really seek out careers and be more business oriented or artistic.
I have a child who
didn't want to go to college and now he's graduating in a month and he's so excited and enrolled himself and already picked his class time and stuff.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Magdalena Resendiz and I'm currently a senior at Los Angeles International Charter High School.
When I first came to Leach's I transferred my second semester of freshman year because I started at a private high school, but at the private high school I didn't belong, my grades were good but I wasn't passing.
When I first transferred to Laches, I felt like instantly I felt that connection with the community.
There was everyone helping me and after along the lines, yes, I had my issues and I struggled a lot academically, but I'm the first in my family to have applied to like four universities and got accepted to all of them.
I'm the first to have received executive honor roll.
I am so proud of everything I have accomplished, but that is because of my teachers, how much they've had one-on-one time with me, how much they've helped me, how much I've had grown because of this school, how much my friends have been in this family.
It's more than just teachers at a school, it's a community, it is a family, and I really hope you guys give everyone else that chance that I had to experience this school.
Thank you.
Good morning my name is Zimmer Garcia I'm currently a senior at Los Angeles International Charter High School.
These past four years I spent at this school have been beyond what I imagined.
At first when I finished eighth grade and when my parents decided to send me to this school at first I was a little bit reluctant because it was a school that I had never heard of.
It was in an area that I had never heard of.
I didn't know anybody over there I would have to start new and right now to this day
When I look back at these past four years, they have been nothing but great memories, great people.
All the teachers we've had over the years, they've all been wonderful.
They take their time, and they talk to you.
You can talk to them.
They're a friend.
They're like family to you.
And it's just something wonderful that I feel like other schools do not have, that they are so close to their students and how they are willing to go so far for them.
And it's just something very important to me when it comes to a high school experience.
So I hope that you could take this and get this.
Thank you.
I'm just going to interject.
We appreciate that you appreciate each other.
But traditionally, we ask that there not be any clapping or noise from the audience.
So you can maybe be silent in your appreciation.
Thank you.
Hello my name is Araceli Torres.
I am a junior currently and like Ms.
Moreno said I am a student that is a part of the LGBT community.
I'm also a student with disabilities and I am a student with anxiety so this is kind of nerve wracking to be up here.
But this school has definitely increased my confidence in coming up here and I want it to be that not only for myself but other kids amongst our community to have this.
We're not we understand that OK our epidemics do need improvement but I think we are a clear representation that each student isn't meant for a cookie cutter.
They understand that and they have molded each individual student to where they are at and how to increase it.
And I think with that.
that they themselves have been in and out, for me personally, one-on-one, when I need it, how I need it, they're always there, time.
So thank you for your time.
Good morning.
My name is Joshua Angel.
I'm a senior at LAI.
And I just want to say that I'm very thankful for Laches and the opportunities that they provided for me.
There's a lot of things that have happened in my life that could have really thrown me off track.
And I'm very proud to say that I was accepted into my dream schools thanks to the school.
how they guided me throughout these four years and I hope that you could renew the school so that other students could have the same experience and you know go to the places where they want to be because that's very rare where we live.
Thank you.
Good morning my name is Rafael Gmez I have been attending LHS for four years I'm currently a senior and throughout the years I've been at LHS I've seen a few changes in myself as well where I personally would never talk to teachers simply because it's not a you know not a student to student type of relationship but I slowly noticed that I've been talking to a few of my teachers such as Mr. Restrepo and Mr. Moreno I'm able to communicate with them such as
as if they were my own peers.
Same with Miss Sims.
I feel very comfortable being able to talk to them about grades or anything related to that matter.
And with this information, I'm hoping that you guys are able to take this into reconsideration.
Thank you.
Good morning I'm Gianna Garcia and I'm also a senior and I've attended Lake Chisholm since I was a freshman and going into high school I wasn't prepared for high school or even college and I was like I didn't feel like comfortable but like I grew to be comfortable I like had challenges and stuff but like the teachers and the staff really supported me like Ms.
Hernandez like she'll make time for us if we need help with like our college admissions or any
anything like that.
So I'm just, I'm grateful that I went to this school and that I got accepted to the colleges that I applied to.
Oh, hello.
My name is Sam Yogi Showy.
I am a sophomore.
And I currently attend Laches High School.
Back in 2018, I had just moved from my house to Highland Park area.
And I really didn't know schools out here.
And my auntie found this school, Laches High School.
And I didn't know too much about it.
And I didn't really know anybody there.
I knew one person.
At my old school, the teachers, they really didn't care about me.
They didn't care about my grades, academics, and they just wanted me to be in class every day.
But at LHS, they actually helped me.
They'll go one-on-one basically with me, Mr. Moreno, Ms.
Shield.
They always helped me.
for anything I need and I could really talk to them.
And I made many, many good friends and bonds.
And I'm currently an AB student and I'm an O school, I was a CMD student.
So I just want to thank Laches for helping me without that.
And- Time.
Thank you.
My name is Jaquay Franklin.
I'm currently an 11th grader at Laches.
I came from Englewood High School and I had just moved to Highland Park and I had to wake up at 5 o'clock in the morning every day to go to school.
It was a two-hour bus ride, and I got tired of it.
Coming back home, I'd get tired.
I wasn't able to do homework.
I couldn't really focus in class, so I had to make a decision.
Ms.
Sims and Ms.
Hernandez came to my house, and they offered me a chance so I could be able to do better.
I had different possibilities at this school, so I made a decision, and I came to Laches, and since I've been here, the school's just been family towards me.
I met a lot of friends.
I just hope that other students can be able to see that, that Laches is a good school, and that you all can be able to see that.
My name is Nalini.
I'm a senior.
I transferred from a Catholic school.
And I wasn't really doing good my freshman year.
And then I transferred to Laches.
And I did so well that I'm in honor roll now.
And I showed my parents that, you know, they could trust in me and they have faith in me that I will graduate.
And I will be joining the police academy once I graduate.
So I hope you help us.
And thank you.
Hi, good morning.
I'm Joanna Rodriguez.
I'm a parent of a senior and a freshman there at Leches.
My senior began there when she was a freshman.
At that time, the administration running the school made me kind of not have confidence in the school.
I was thinking of transferring her out.
Ms.
Sims came in and made a complete change.
She has brought upon a culture where the kids feel safe.
We are aware that maybe test taking doesn't really show what the kids are capable of, or are not great at test taking.
But she has set a culture there where everybody feels comfortable.
Our mental health is a priority.
If you're not all set here, it's hard for you to go to school and focus.
It's an open door policy there.
Everybody feels comfortable talking to her.
I have so much confidence in this school that I am really here to plead that you keep it open because I do have a son who will be coming in from LAUSD with an IEP.
He has ADHD, ODD.
I've been struggling for many years.
I'm his biggest advocate, go to all the IEP meetings.
Good afternoon board members my name is Valerie Rodriguez and I am a senior who has had the privilege to have been a student at Los Angeles international charter high school for all my four years.
I admit at the first sight of LAI I was very hesitant and dreaded that I was forced to enroll because of the small campus and uniforms.
But now I can confidently say that I wouldn't have wanted to go to school anywhere else.
I am a part of the softball team, student government, and I'm enrolled in advanced placement classes.
I grew many friendships and became a part of a family outside of my own.
Academically over the years, the school has improved through testing due to the teachers who put so much effort to get us college ready.
Unfortunately, I scored low on my testing, but it didn't stop me.
I have been accepted and will be attending a four-year college this upcoming school year in Arizona.
In addition, they have offered me two scholarships to attend the university.
It would be very disappointing if Lechas had to close its doors to the community because other people deserve an opportunity like we had.
Time.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Zecor Rodriguez and I am currently a freshman at LAI.
When I first got to this school I was very scared because I knew nobody and for the first three weeks I had no friends because I would hang out with my sister and her friends.
So sad.
But I joined the volleyball team, which helped me break out of my shell and get more friends and be comfortable around everybody.
So with that, I joined the basketball team, then the softball team.
I was the only freshman on the volleyball and basketball team, so I was very proud of that.
I have anxiety, so I'm shaking right now.
I'm sorry.
My brother will be attending if the school
stays open next year and I know he will be better and appreciate the school like I do and I'm very thankful for everybody there, the teachers, the students, the staff.
Thank you.
And I assume that's the end of the public commenters, so I'm gonna, at this point, close the public hearing.
We're now ready for board member discussion.
I'm gonna turn to Sue Burr, our liaison, to get us going.
So I think you can see from the agenda item that the advisory commission did not take action.
They were unable to reach a conclusion about this.
But it's safe to say that many of the members of the ACCS were quite moved by the testimony, especially by students and community members and parents on behalf of the school.
I'll just say for me I think it's quite a unique school.
I would like to just take a point of personal privilege and read the intent language of the Charter Schools Act and it says that charter schools are established for a variety of reasons but two of them are to increase learning opportunities for all pupils with special emphasis on expanded learning experiences for pupils who are identified as academically low achieving.
And secondly, that it's to provide parents and pupils with expanded choices in the types of educational opportunities that are available within the public school system.
And I think you see in this school, both of those provisions are firmly in place.
So, with that said, I would like to ask Ms.
Sims if she could come back up and ask some specific questions, answer some specific questions, and then I'd like to hear from other members before we talk about a motion.
I think there may be other questions for Ms.
Sims, so after you finish your questions, we'll see before she sits down what other ones there may be.
Morning.
Thank you, Ms.
Burr, for calling me up.
Sure.
Thank you for coming, and I should also express our appreciation to everyone who came.
I know many of you drove all night to get here.
Yes, they're AP testing too, so a lot had to stay behind today.
So just know how appreciative we are of the passion that you feel for this school.
I think you kind of glossed over a very traumatic event that happened at the school, and I'd like you to talk a little bit about that, because to me, having looked at a lot of data on test scores, when you see something happen and there's clearly sort of a marker and things go bad,
Something happened there that I'd like you to share and then I'll come back to another couple questions.
And it's difficult for me to share because I'm coming from Compton Unified myself.
I'm an inner city student where my science teacher said the best you can hope for as a minority African American student is that you graduate from high school and become the manager at a fast food restaurant.
So I'm emotional about them because they're me.
They're students that struggle.
They're students that have been in trouble.
They are students whose parents need support.
They're students that need to feel safe.
And if 50% of them are coming from the school that
trying to send them back to, they're not gonna be safe.
And this experience was traumatic for me even to hear about it because I remember a student being killed at Dominguez High when I taught there, when I taught in Compton.
And basically it was the day that LAUSD had the bomb threat and they sent all the school's kids home.
And he was crossing the street on Figueroa and was hit by an 18-wheeler.
And when your children see that,
how do you expect that they're able to really function?
So they experienced that and then that same month, their entire executive director, their entire leadership board and the board of directors were gone.
And they went through three directors in just that one year and finally got to me and I was very hesitant about coming because I knew the school was in trouble.
And I also knew that two years wasn't enough time to turn it around.
But since I came, I have adhered to what LACOE has asked of me, implementing the courses for intervention.
implementing the CPM, the academic rigor.
We have 11 new elective courses.
The reason why our kids are not having the behavior issues they were having before is because now they have dance and yoga.
They're exerting a lot of energy.
We have students with autism taking AP classes.
They couldn't do that at their other schools.
And they're on honor roll.
So we tried to take that tragedy and turn it around.
And the first step in that is
is giving them a safe place to heal, and does healing happen overnight?
It doesn't.
But they're scared, and they don't want to go back to these places that they've been abused or mistreated.
So we are getting a lot of students that are enrolling in the 10th and the 11th grade that we have not had time to fully prepare, but we're dedicated to that.
And I feel like, honestly, the guidance that we were given is now being used against us, because we've done what we were asked to do, but we need time to show.
But these kids are showing you.
Last year, 38 students graduated.
36 were accepted to a four-year university, despite not doing well on their SBAC.
because they soared in every other area, and they were able to use their alternative data that we weren't able to use in our petition.
And so that's the reason why we're here today.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it, and I appreciate your emotion.
And I apologize.
That's OK.
I really do.
I feel exactly the same way you do.
Can I just ask a couple specific questions then related to some of the things that we heard?
What is the WASC status of the school?
We got a full six-year accreditation.
What we were told was for the rigorous, if you even, and I could forward the email, our chairperson said we put that in every school's report because every school can improve academics.
And what we are advising is that you do some type of an intervention or you guys start implementing Saturday Academies, which we do now, we have Saturday Academy, and they said put AVID in the school.
I'll stop now and see if other people have questions.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ms.
Burr.
Have some for you as well.
Are there others who have questions for Ms.
Sims?
Okay, Ting, and then we'll go around to Patricia and Eileen, and then I'll come in the queue.
Thank you.
Sorry, I'm getting emotional.
I'm sorry.
No, no, no, it's OK.
So yeah, one of the questions I had was the WASC accreditation, because I think that also helps to flesh out a little bit about the culture of the school that we don't necessarily see in quantitative data.
So a couple of other things.
Can you just tell me the number of 11th graders you have and the number of 12th graders you have?
11th graders right now we have 41 and 12th graders is 48.
Okay, so I'm looking at your, I mean, it's 153 students in the school, very small school.
So when we're looking at this data too, we know that one or two students makes a huge difference in the percentages.
And then when you get down to 41 students in a class, especially when we're looking at high school and there is the CAFs, it's for that one 11th grade only.
So some of the fluctuations.
And so I see the test scores,
One of the pieces of charter law is academic achievement.
At the same time, you're also serving, as you pointed out, students who may not have been achieving in other schools, and you're providing that.
I will also say from my experience, and I think one of the reasons I got emotional is because I know that, excuse me,
In a small school, when you have a really close community, when a death occurs, it does really impact.
And that happened to one of my academies where a
a teacher passed away and our test scores tanked in math that year.
And I completely understand and empathize with that.
And then it does take several years to try to tune that up again, especially when in high school, again, you're only tested that one grade level.
So, sorry.
I feel the same way.
Thank you.
I got napkins here.
I think that it's important to note that the report saying that we decline in scores every year is not true.
If you look at the data yourself, you'll see we plummeted.
We did hit rock bottom.
But we put those things in place, and every year our test scores actually were raising.
We increased.
We didn't decrease every year after we hit the bottom.
But we hit the bottom, and we realized that.
And we also take fault for not updating the dashboard.
But we were in crisis.
We were in survival mode.
And we were trying to ensure that our kids didn't drop out, and that they didn't
that they receive the counseling they need, that they receive the support they need, and that we are the only high school in the city of Hermann.
We actually sit in Hermann, not Highland Park.
And we are the only high school there.
And we petitioned for the middle school because the nearest one is three miles away.
And that is why we got the Prop 39.
And parents were asking, well, can we get a middle school here?
And we got that Prop 39 to bring that middle school.
If we have these kids from sixth grade, imagine what they'll be doing on their tests in the 11th grade.
But if we're getting them as 10th and 11th graders because their district schools are putting them out, are turning their backs on them, or their parents are saying this is their last chance before they drop out, they have no place else to go, and we're taking them.
But they're not back in the system.
They're in school.
So do we close down their school and then they just don't go?
Because a lot of the kids are saying they won't go if they can't be here and be safe.
So just last two points that I have.
One is I appreciate the number of opportunities you provide, especially with such a small high school of 153, the AP classes, the sports, and some of the other things that we're hearing from the students.
And lastly, I just really wanna praise the students who came today and how articulate they were and very passionate about their school.
We hear a lot of students who are passionate about our school, but it was very clear from them that how they benefited from their experience at the school.
So thank you.
Thank you.
Good morning, Ms.
Rucker.
Good morning.
Well, first of all, I want to congratulate you all for making it here because I know you had a lot of drama with the travel up here.
Two plane flights were canceled.
And I actually appreciate that you were able to be here today rather than facing the drama of coming back for another scheduled hearing because it would not have felt good, especially for the students who are making the effort to get here.
for the young men and women who are here today.
I really want to tell you how much I appreciate the effort and initiative you showed to get here.
My questions are about the information provided by the department staff and also by the county office concerning what they identified
as deficiencies in the program.
And in asking these questions, let me begin by saying, I believe I agree with you that you're being held accountable for guidance that you're trying to address, and that it seems like that guidance that you've been given are some things that are being held.
I think I agree with you on that, but I do wanna ask some specific questions.
So in your petition, you are proposing to add some additional grade levels?
We wanted to start with sixth grade next year.
We do, I believe you have in your red folders, several hundred signatures from the community because parents were saying that what they're finding they're having trouble is
if they have to be at work at 8 a.m.
and they have to bring a kid to high school over here and to a middle school three miles away, it was posing difficulties for them.
And we also understood that after in 2016, this was after I got to the school, when they did reduce the lease, the size of the amount of land that we could use, that we were going to need to have more space in order to grow the program.
So, we did ask LAUSD for Prop 39 and it was granted to us so that we would be able to start those programs.
We do have students that are enrolled tentatively if there is going to be a middle school.
And we realized that the school needs to overcome some obstacles.
So we were just surprised that maybe the middle school and the IS program would have been denied but the high school would still continue.
That's kind of what we felt would happen because we knew that at the time we thought the alternative data and the performance and that our kids are going to UC Davis.
They're being accepted to USC and UCLA.
They're not being accepted there because they're not performing.
And we did implement, as they asked us to, we implemented the honors program in every grade level.
So now even ninth graders are taking honors courses.
So we're not doing the same thing over and over.
As was stated, we are implementing something every single year to improve the students' performance.
OK, so the answer to my question about whether or not you're adding another grade
Oh yes, yes, we would like to add a grade.
Yeah, so the answer is yes, that's what your petition's asking for.
This goes back to, for my colleagues on the dais, why I said in the previous hearing that I'm a little confused about what it is we're attempting to do in these conversations because given what you have stated and the conversations and the information that's been presented by students as well as by you and members of your team, your faculty,
and staff about the trauma that has gone on with the school, particularly with the upheaval in leadership and some of the work that you clearly know you have to overcome.
I'm not sure I understand how expanding the school with everything else that you actually need to address actually will accomplish
what you believe can be accomplished given everything that you have to work on.
So I have a concern that your petition, if it's approved, would add more grade levels, more complexity to the work that you already have to address.
And I don't see how adding that grade level in what you've written in the petition actually clearly addresses the problems that you agree are there.
The second question I have is about the things that have been identified that your educational program doesn't address.
Can you tell me some things about how you're going to fix your EL plan?
And I need you in answering the question not to tell me what you've done,
and not to explain to me what your outcomes have been.
This says that you don't have a clear description on your plan for serving ELs and that it doesn't appear to cite the correct assessments that are required and you do not have a clear plan for reclassification.
So I need you to explain to me how exactly, and I know you're the third director, but what exactly is the work that you have done
that you have put your hands on to direct your staff to do to address this concern?
So we have an EL coordinator, and the EL coordinator is pulling the students and testing with the students at least 20 minutes per week.
We also put all of the EL students into that intervention group, which again was a recommendation from LEGO.
And so when the students reclassify, we continue to follow them.
The period that we will follow for would be two years, but if the student, let's say they reclassify in 10th grade, they're out in two years.
If they reclassify in ninth, we still will provide them the services.
And we did state that in our meeting with LACOE when we did the capacity hearing.
Okay, so that's not clear to me in the written material that I have read through.
Do you have any, and it's okay on this next question to answer no, do you have any idea of how many long-term English learners, because you have high school students, do you have any idea how many long-term English learners are in your student population?
We only have four students that are EL in our school.
We don't have a huge EL population and we've never had a huge EL population.
I believe last year we had about 11 and six were reclassified.
So we just, one did move on because she graduated.
So right now we do only have about four students that are in the program.
But they're also being able to be seen in the tutoring program as well.
So they go into the tutoring program and then the doors are open for Saturday school for them as well.
But they do want to one also with their counselor.
Okay, so then as it relates to for those four students.
that you know are long-term English learners.
They're not long-term, though.
Those kids will reclassify this year.
They get the EO classification if Spanish is their first language or another language is their first language.
These students are, they're scoring at the reclassification level every time we test them.
But those that are currently in the program, we monitor them through assessments, through the Reading Plus program, because the Reading Plus program gives us the data to show so the kids will read for a certain amount of time.
They answer the questions.
It is all data-based.
It is nothing that the school prepares.
The program gives us back the reports, and it's showing that those students are leveling up by two grade levels in a year.
So just to put some perspective, we do have two students that transferred to our school.
They're international students that transferred to our school, and they are now reading above the ninth grade level through that program.
So we are tracking them.
Okay, that wasn't the question I was going to ask.
Let me ask you the question.
So for the four students you told me that you are tracking as long-term English learners, what exactly is in the plan based on the guidance that you're telling me you've been working to address from LACO?
What is the integrated and designated English language development program that you have for those students, for those four students?
Well, based on the guidance from LACOE, now mind you too that we just changed coordinators.
I understand, I understand all of that.
Okay, so based on the previous guidance, we put together the intervention classes for them.
This was part of the plan for developing the EL students.
It was through tutoring, through testing, through monitoring, through their intervention class.
And they are taking the, they do take the silt and we do get- The alpac.
I'm sorry, the alpac, yes.
I have all this in my head and it's just- I got it, I got it.
So that's why I said, I know you mean the LPAC.
They do take the LPAC.
And so we're tracking them based on performance, so we just reassess and reevaluate them.
But outside of the reclassification, we reassess and reevaluate them each month that we give them an assessment.
So they have their formal assessments and they have their informal assessments, and they do those with the EL coordinator.
So she has tracking sheets.
So every student that's in the EL program has a tracking sheet.
It shows where they started with their comprehension, with their reading skill and their reading level.
And then it tracks how much they're progressing.
So we give each student almost like an IEP, a goal for progression and a goal for when
we feel like they've reached that progression, then they're able to, you know, yearly we test for reclassification.
But every time that there, if there is a student that doesn't reclassify, then they get the interventions.
They get more of the interventions that we had put in place.
The thing on the EL plan, it did say Casey, and that was the outdated test.
We just, we missed that when we edited, we missed bringing that out.
But we acknowledge that.
Look, like most of the people in this room, I have a clippings file.
I get an article sent to me from newspapers all the time.
And I'm a high school English teacher.
It drives me nuts when I read an article that's been published and somebody got paid really good money for it and there's typos in it.
So I understand the typos stuff.
But here's the issue.
Some of the things I just ask you to articulate to me to address the criteria about an integrated and designated English language development plan
While you touched on some of the things that would be required in the plan, you do understand you didn't explain all of those things.
But further, the point that's being made by what LACO has written in their report
making the recommendation to deny.
And the report that was written by the department staff on making their recommendation to deny is that none of what you've explained to me is clearly articulated in your plan.
So while you may be busy doing a lot of things,
The question is, are you doing the correct things?
And how do we know that if it's not apparent in the core of what is supposed to be your defining plan, not only to address the guidance and the concerns that have been expressed to you by LACO, but what will clearly continue to be continuing concerns by this board and the department
if you don't know how to write that out and address all that criteria.
And I apologize that our EO coordinator isn't here either to give you all the ins and outs.
And I'll be honest with you, as the director, there's so much that I do.
I don't have everything memorized.
I'm looking at the plan in my head, though, but she's doing AP testing right now, and we had to decide that she had to stay back.
But like I said, we do acknowledge that there are some things that we have to address, and we do acknowledge that there are some things that probably possibly has to be rewritten.
Not probably.
That will have to be rewritten.
We understand that and we acknowledge that and we're ready for it.
I have to tell you, I'm concerned that you said probably.
That tells me you're resistant to even the recommendations or the guidance that's been given.
Not at all.
I have a concern.
It's not a probably.
There are some things that definitely have to be corrected and addressed in your plan.
We need to move on to the next set of questions.
Yes, I agree with you as well.
Elaine, you're next, and then Felice, and then I'll put myself a little further.
So first, let me just thank you all for, all the students for coming, all the staff for coming, and for the continued commitment to this population and the group of students.
I'm clear that this is a, it's a small, but it's a safe environment.
It's an environment that students have gone to after not feeling safe and successful in other locations.
I know the area of Los Angeles, and I also want to thank L.A.
County and the Department of Ed for their analysis, and also thank L.A.
County for their oversight and their support.
So I have several questions about the process.
The way I understand it, this was a school that's been around 10 years.
It was authorized by LAUSD, and LAUSD authorized it.
On the renewal, they denied.
So L.A.
County heard it.
They authorized it for five years.
Oversight now denied.
now coming to us.
So this is not a brand new school with a year or two.
It's gone through cycles and having led schools, I know schools go through cycles, but I have several questions.
First of all, as far as the suspension rate, it's my understanding if students are suspended in a school and they transfer to a different site, the suspensions go with them on the tracking if it's during that school year.
I believe that.
So that's one issue I've heard actually from continuation high schools who take students from traditional high schools.
So I know you said that you didn't believe the suspension rate was reflective of what practices actually occur at your school.
And I just am aware of that in other sites and I'll just set that one aside because I do know that if students have been suspended at other schools during the school year and the kids transfer to you, we don't lose that record.
I just want to make that comment.
But I do want to talk to you as the executive director about how you wrote your plan, because I have several questions about the plan, and that's under which we have to evaluate.
So what was the process that you went through to write the petition for renewal?
As the executive director, it's a small school, small team.
How did you go around about that process?
Well, initially I had a different coordinator.
So I was basing off the recommendations of LACOE, the recommendations of WASC, and my conversations with my previous coordinator.
I had asked, I think it was at the end of the, at the beginning of the 2017 school year, if I could make a materials revision for the independent studies program because options for youth was closing down.
80 students would otherwise have gone to Franklin and that school was across the street from us.
So I was told no to put that, that I would be able to put that into this because we were too close to renewal.
So, I went off of that recommendation and that's why it was in this plan.
Once this petition was written, then I received a text message from the new coordinator that said LACOE doesn't believe that we should include it, but it was already written and ready for submission based on the old recommendation that it should go in as a materials revision.
So, that's how that got in that plan.
But basically, I looked at our LCAP, too.
I looked at our CPSA.
And I looked at deeper than just what the test scores were reporting.
Through the SSC, the School Site Council, things had come up that we needed to ensure that the kids had culture, there was safety, and things like that.
And our discipline policy is written into that plan.
But I will tell you this.
I was told these words, your plan had been approved before, so basically you're just adding your new stuff to your plan.
And so that's what, I'm sorry, but that's what we did.
So we went back and adjusted the things that
that we understood the laws have changed on this, the laws have changed here, the student needs have changed, so we adjusted those and then we kept the core of what the petition was because it's based on the mission.
So let me just say, I have no doubt that your leadership has provided a safe and secure environment and a renewed opportunity and vision for the school.
The problem is that the analysis says that 8 of the 15 requirements are not met.
And while you just adjusted, if we evaluate just that charter petition, it has API, it has Casey, it has SELT.
Those are things we don't do at the state anymore and haven't for a while.
And so I'm wondering whether it was just like, since it was, I'm just asking and I'm just wondering.
If it was approved before, we'll just do the same thing, but things have changed.
And so the concern and kind of building on what Member Rucker said is we expect English language development to be taught in a little different way.
I think WASC and asking you for rigor is important.
We want that in all of our schools.
And I guess I'm hearing from L.A.
County that they actually gave you recommendations and you're saying we've done what L.A.
County told us to do to get better and yet L.A.
County and their analysis said you didn't follow the recommendations.
And I think they did appear to exercise oversight and support.
So can you talk about that tension about how the direction to improve with their year authorizer, you're asking for us to now authorize,
They authorized you to supervise, and then you did or didn't do what they recommended you needed to do.
But Ms.
Strauss, we did.
The recommendation was that we implement, the direct recommendation was CPM math, and we did that.
We did that in 2017.
Intervention classes, we did that.
Inside of our classes, though, we used,
some of the Sadai strategies, we scaffold, we do all of that so it's not just the EL students that are progressing, that it's all students that are getting access to these strategies and the thinking maps and just all of the things that are creating a clearer thinker and helping them to be more organized and to better comprehend and read and understand.
So we use also some of our
strategies that are written in our IEPs, we use those directly in our classrooms as well because it is a catcher's mitt for some of those students that really haven't been identified that are transferring in at such a late stage.
But I will tell you, I questioned about when we wrote the petition because
It did say API on there as a criteria, and I even said, but we don't do that anymore, so how do I write that I've met this goal if this is what we're supposed to write to and it doesn't even exist?
So I was told, but you can't change that.
That is what's written, so.
I didn't go back and extract it out of the EL plan, and I should have, and I take ownership for that, and that's why I'm saying I do know, Ms.
Rucker, there are things that we have to fix, but I think that my confusion came from so many different voices because of the different coordinators telling me different things.
I have one more question.
I just so appreciate you sincerely trying to address the questions, honestly.
And I'm just trying to understand the pieces that we are required to evaluate.
So that's why I'm asking.
There was a question about your employee qualifications, and I just would like you to address what you know about the problem in that area.
Well, the question that was asked to us in the capacity hearing was, why does our operations manager have athletic knowledge and CIF knowledge on the employee qualifications list when you look at the employment, I'm sorry, job description?
Job description, I'm sorry, I drew a blank.
And that is because if you look at our organization chart, which is in our charter petition, which Letco has a copy of, the operations manager is the direct supervisor to our athletic director.
So she has to know, because she's paying those bills, she's authorizing, well, they come to me, but she authorizes the checks for if we're paying CIF fees,
What are the CIF fees?
Are we being overcharged when there's referees and things like that?
So she has to know it.
Is it just about the athletic piece?
No.
So we have a teacher who has a CTE credential that teaches our dancing yoga program.
She's on the CTE credential through LACO.
When she joined the program, and what we were originally told,
was that when she clears it, she will receive her EO authorization.
But it wasn't until we got our new coordinator that stated, no, she needs an EO waiver.
So we did apply for that EO waiver.
They do have the documentation that that has been applied for.
Also, when we went back to check, we had her to check to make sure that the authorization had come through.
They had it coded as something else.
So we sent a letter to CTC and we let them know that this is not what we applied for.
We gave them a copy and they said that they are looking into it now for us.
So do you believe it's just that one staff member?
Do you believe that's the only issue on the qualifications?
I'm just asking.
Yes, it is, because every other teacher is completely qualified.
But I will tell you this, we were misdirected because I received an email from the new coordinator that our environmental science teacher was not properly credentialed.
So I disputed that.
I told him that he was properly credentialed and these were his credentials and this is why he could teach the science.
He told me that he needed a biological science or a life science credential.
First of all, he's a chemistry teacher teaching environmental science.
So he wouldn't get a biological science credential.
Secondly, in 2015, life science credentials become obsolete.
So I could not understand why we were being told that.
I really appreciate your thoroughness.
I know we have some other questions.
So I thank you.
I just want to ask LACO because they're the ones that did the announcement.
Okay.
That's fine.
All right.
That's all the rest of it.
Okay.
Do you have any more questions?
Wonderful Voices of your students and the work that you've done over the last couple of years and there have been increases posted in ELA and math since 2016 that was obvious on the charts and your graduation rates are very high and obviously you're getting kids into college There's a lot of good work going on there Yeah, I wanted to ask
The other two questions, I think we got a little bit of insight perhaps from board member Strauss about the suspension rates being so high.
Maybe some of that is being carried with the students from other schools, but I want to ask you about what you're doing in that area to provide alternatives to suspension so that we can hear your response to that.
So, one of the things that we started implementing was the one-to-one counseling with the students that are coming in with the behavior issues, because like our counselor explained, we have students, maybe about 7% of our population, that are juvenile delinquent.
And I wish we had more time because in one of the clips and the thing, you would have heard the student tell their story and how he would have gone to jail if LHS didn't accept him.
So we're seeing an influx of students that are coming in from other schools, the neighboring schools that they would otherwise attend, that they are no longer being allowed to be in school there.
And they're coming to us.
We've not expelled them.
We have put together a counseling program for them.
We also work one-to-one with their probation officers, and I'm very heavily involved in that because, like I said, I was an inner-city student, so I know the importance of that.
And then also, we pull them.
So, we pull them, we monitor, and we track.
Every two weeks, we're looking at their grades, and we give them a progression plan that may include grade and behavior, because not all of these students are part of the IEP program.
But we still, as one of the students said, every single student, we meet their needs individually.
And those are some of the things that we're doing.
Some of the behavior that we did see, yes, some of the suspensions do come with them.
But some of the behaviors we were seeing was drugs, drug abuse.
And so I actually called LACO because I was questioning the suspension.
And I was told directly, but you have to do what's listed in your charter.
And your charter petition says, if there's drugs on campus,
the suspension was part of that policy.
We've written in the PBIS, we've been going to the PBIS training, and our students are now no longer having those issues.
If you look at our suspension rate this year,
It's not.
They're not.
And we're not having those types of problems because we did implement that one-to-one counseling with the students, but not only with the students, with the parents.
So the students and the parents are coming in, and they're getting sessions, and we make plans for all of them and goals, and they're on a tracking system.
So now we're not seeing those behavior issues.
We just had to get over that hump.
But you can't expect there not to be behavior issues when you're getting kids from a juvenile system that wants to test the waters and see what they can get away with.
But that was the reason why we saw that increase.
Thank you.
And you already mentioned that with respect to math, you've been putting in place the CPM math.
And I just wondered if you have, you mentioned with respect to math and improvement, excuse me.
With respect to math, you're seeing improvements in math?
Can you say what more you're doing beyond the CPM program?
We also have math intervention, and we have our ELs that are taking that class, our special education students, and we do allow our lowest performing 11th graders into that class.
Again, we're now doing SBAC practices two a year.
So the students since last year have been taking SBAC practice and AP practice and SAT practice twice a year.
So one in each semester.
And we're doing our Saturday academies to address our math issue.
But we also have, we're also doing supplementals.
So we're fusing math into the other subjects.
They do this cross-curricular project where they start in the ninth grade.
The ninth grade, 10th, 11th, and 12th graders do it across the board, and they're doing it throughout their classes.
So it's a huge math problem, but you'll see it happening in art, history, English.
So we're attacking math in every place that we can because we know that that was our greatest problem.
Matt, you are next.
I do want to be able to move us to the county office soon, but if you have a quick question and I saw Kim, go ahead.
Well, I, morning, I won't be, I'll be brief and it's just a clarifying question.
Actually a question and clarifying question.
Students with disabilities, are you part of a SELPA?
Who's monitoring?
Southwest.
Yes, and we have been great on all of our audits and our observations and through the monitoring through Southwest, we are compliant, completely compliant.
So I want to make sure I understand your position because our fellow board members have been great about asking some really great questions and I just want to thank you, number one, for standing here and taking it all.
It's not easy and I want to thank your students and your community for coming.
They definitely love you and you're obviously a passionate leader.
So there are two issues in my mind.
One is the scores, the comparison scores.
And we can debate those scores back and forth for a long time in terms of how you compare yourself to other schools versus how LACO.
The other issue that I think is creating the most
The most questions, and I want to make sure I understand your position, is the errors in the petition.
So the errors in the petition in terms of what LACOA deems as competency, the ability of the school to move the system forward, and there's some confidence issues.
But it doesn't seem like you gave LACOA much choice.
The petition had errors.
But what I hear you saying is many of those errors were based on the guidance of LACOA.
Yes, so we had a different coordinator, and then in October, we had a different coordinator.
And when you're trying to abide by what LACOE is telling you, but then it's different,
I went and met with them in October, and I sat down with Ciccarelli and Mr. Hartman, and I did tell them that there are discrepancies, and I showed it, in what I was told and what I'm being told now, and I don't know where to go with this.
What improvements do you own in this?
I'm sorry, say that one more time.
What improvements do you own?
So in other words, yeah, there's some guidance barriers related.
We need continued professional development, and that was one of the things that was in our plan.
We also, we're not, we're not,
that much different than the students, we kind of need to know that our authorizers are supporting us too, and that just because we're questioning them, that we don't feel like we're under attack, and which is what we felt like, because we were kind of reprimanded for going to the CTC behind their back, so to speak, but that wasn't it.
I just kind of wanted to clarify that whole credential thing, and kind of got a reprimand for not just doing it through LACO.
But our previous coordinator said, when in doubt, go to the state, ask the state.
And that's what we did.
But where I take ownership is that I know that this petition has errors that need to be addressed and rewritten.
I understand that.
I also understand that
We need to address and find where we can improve these students and we really need to catch the transfers because it is the transfer students that are struggling.
It is not the ones that we've had in our school.
So we know that we have to find a way to address our transfer students.
I'll put this into perspective too.
This year, 12% of the students testing this year are transfer students and SPED students.
6% are SPED.
But we have a lot of those students that have been with us, so we've been tracking them, making sure that they're going to be able to take this test and pass this test.
So with the petition, the errors, I take ownership.
I'm the director.
I should have caught them.
875 pages is hard to catch every error but I should have caught them and that's why I'm saying I'm just pleading that the students are not held responsible for any of my mistakes and that they're not held responsible for
any of you know us being held accountable for some of the things we were told to do and then later told not to do and you know the confusion and just not being held accountable for what happened to this school that was out of everyone's control.
But but as the executive director what happens at that school I take full accountability for.
You're welcome.
And thank you for your question.
Good afternoon and thank you as well as all the students for sharing the experience of your school and the college going rates are very impressive and really something to be very proud of.
I am a little concerned as I not just look at the sort of jolt that happened in 2016
Part of, I think, what is equally concerning is that even before 2016, that it was in the low teens for math, so that there's a history that precedes this tumultuous event, which I'm sure, understandably, was very traumatic.
But it was at 12% before for math proficiency.
wanting to hear what else you have envisioned for the future.
I think you reflected on some of the recommendations from LACOE around Saturday Academy.
But what else is in store?
And then also, we haven't really talked about the ELA scores.
And I think
Actually, there's been tremendous progress, right, where you had the low year on ELA going to 41%, and then coming back up to 49, so you're showing progress.
But it also still puts you guys in the bottom half, whether it be like those resident schools or comparison schools, and if you can just address a little bit of the plans on ELA.
Yeah, so with the ELA, we have noticed that through the tracking that that intervention class is really working in terms of the ELA test scores and the ELA population.
A lot of what we have found out, which is why we revamped our college prep classes to include SBAC practice, is that the students are not scoring the lowest on the math problems that are written as math problems.
They're scoring the lowest on the math problems that are written as sentences, word problems, because they're not clearly understanding what they're asking them.
But when they're asked in a different way, the kids perform.
So what we know is that we have to improve the comprehension and their reading level in order for them to be able to be successful because math is such more convoluted subject, it's more complicated, there's so many steps.
And when you're dealing with students that are special needs, students that have high anxiety, and our students do understand and have expressed to me
that miss, when we're taking like an SAT, it's different because we know it's for us.
But when we take the SBAC, we know that this is for the school and their anxiety level increases.
And it's like, okay, calm down.
So we have to put in the counseling, the test taking strategies.
And that was the reason why we said, okay, just having the CPM is not working.
So, now we have math honors in 9th grade, we have math honors in 10th, 11th, and 12th, we have the AP courses too because we wanted to push that rigor, but we also are having the Saturday Academy and the kids are having math camp.
So, our calculus teacher actually went to one of those
like one of those shows, like a family feud type thing.
I can't think of off the top of my head the show, but they pay the audience member, so they use the money in order to start doing Math Camp.
So we do understand that there are needs, and when I tell you that we are there and we are implementing every strategy
that we can get our hands on for these students, we are.
We have college prep as an elective course, and that is the name of the class.
The class is called college prep.
And in that class, we do the math test prep strategies for them.
So we are knowing that this year's scores are going to be much better, even with the students that transferred, because they're getting that extra dose on the weekends.
Thank you very much for all of the answers to all of our questions.
And I would like to ask the folks from LA County to come up in case there are any clarifying questions that people want to ask of them.
And then we're going to complete our discussion and figure out how we want to vote.
Yeah, Eileen, you were in the queue for this.
Is there anybody else who wants to be in the queue for any questions here?
Felicia?
for CDE, okay.
My question to LA County staff, thank you for your thorough presentation.
I am interested in the five years that you had oversight and authorization for this charter.
What oversight role did you have?
What kind of directions and support were they given?
And do you feel that they follow the directions?
It was kind of a
I kind of heard not a clear road.
I'm just kind of interested in understanding the role of oversight because we're being asked if we approve it to now take over the oversight.
So I'd like to understand the five-year process.
My understanding is you had a good collaborative process with them in the early years and I'm just to help clarify and understand that.
Yes, thank you for the question.
This was a good school, a school on the rise at the last renewal that was doing very well in all areas academically as well as suspension rates and alternative data.
And I would like to clarify that suspension rate that that
An individual school suspension rate is based on the suspensions at that school.
While there may be a record that transfers that does not affect the actual school suspension rate.
You saw in the slide, we talked about the different, I had several slides that showed the different pieces as far as oversight and what we've done to try to provide support.
We do, at LACO, per Ed Code, you are required to do at least one school site visit.
We do at least two school site visits, and often more, depending on the school.
We do, twice a year, we call all of our charters in, and we do a one-day training with them, and give them specific PD with experts from LACO in different areas.
We also do an annual review where we ask them to create an annual report and speak out on all of their goals and what their action plans are for any unmet goals.
We then meet with them and their leadership team at the end of the year to go over the year and give them specific feedback on the year and what we would like to see moving forward as well.
And then on top of that, we have our coordinators who are that single point of contact and are kind of in a constant communication with them as far as submissions that they have to, things they have to submit to us on a monthly basis and ensuring that they have the resources, pointing them to different resources at LACO if there are more specific needs that our coordinator cannot meet.
Thank you very much.
Sue you had a question?
I don't completely recall your presentation but I just wanted to ask a question about whether or not you considered alternative academic measures before making your recommendation.
It seemed like mostly it was if not exclusively based on CASP data but I just wanted to clarify
No, we absolutely pulled alternative data.
So I don't think we directly tied it to that piece of Ed Code.
But if you look in our report under finding two, we do look at alternative pieces of data such as suspension rate, graduation, chronic absenteeism.
All of those different pieces are part of our report.
We absolutely do take that into account.
I feel like the errors in the petition kind of gave you no choice but to bring this forward.
Can you explain the process with them to help?
mitigate these issues because I feel like given the opportunity to repair what they could, they would have?
Right.
So one of the things we do with all of our renewals is we have a, the year prior to them coming up for renewal, we have a meeting with those schools that are up for renewal.
We give them a binder that has all the different resources, goes through the different criteria, what exactly we'll be looking at.
We have that meeting with them and go through all of those different pieces.
Additionally, we offer to any of our schools that want to turn in their petitions early that we'll do an informal review prior to the official submission so that we can assess if there are any big holes or any missing pieces and give that back to them with that feedback.
But they do have to turn that in early as opposed to sort of waiting to the end when we don't really have the time to do that.
Did they not do that?
Correct.
I just want to sort of give a sense of process.
What I'm thinking is that we have Kim, Patricia, and Ting on the list, and Felicia.
I'd like us to break at some point and get our lunches and bring them back in.
I'm thinking if we can keep ourselves moving efficiently, we can get through this list.
And then thank them for answering our questions, get our lunches for 10 minutes, ask any other questions to CDE, finish our discussion.
Okay, so I know I've saw people getting up and getting snacks and getting restless, so I just wanted to give us a plan.
Sure.
At what point you would like to have a motion that we're actually deliberating on?
After our break.
Okay.
So Kim?
Matt actually asked most of the question.
Just one discrete follow-up question.
Can you share what the high school graduation data was?
I didn't see that in the slides.
They do.
There was also a question, too, I think at one point in their petition.
There was a question between whether they were using the four-year cohort graduation data or a one-year cohort graduation data.
16, 17, 17, 18.
He mentioned it was one of the criteria that they determined.
Right, so the cohort, the 2018 four-year cohort graduation rate was 90%.
We noted within our report, again, that the WASP visiting committee did note that the graduation rate was high, but that there needed to be an increase in rigor in the classroom.
Yeah, thank you.
Good afternoon, and thank you for being here today.
I need to say that we're accustomed at this level, when we have these appeals, to hear disputes about communication problems and about who's telling the truth or who's misrepresenting some information or some misinformation.
But my eyes and my ears immediately perked up when the conversation turned
to the credentialing issue.
So do you all or does the district do the credential monitoring, the assignment monitoring for this charter school?
We actually do on an annual basis for all of our schools check credentials.
So they will submit a list of their staff to us twice a year and we will go through and check those credentials.
And if you notice, I think there was
A lot of the stuff brought up by Ms.
Sims was conversations and was things that we were going back and forth with in the court, but none of those particular pieces were in our report that had nothing to do with any of our findings or any of our recommendations.
Yeah, so that's what I was going to be asking about was a concern about the credentialing issue because it didn't seem to show up in your findings.
But there was a statement made about the authorization for the environmental science teacher that I want to make sure we do correct so that we don't have a misunderstanding about that issue and another opportunity for some misinformation.
In Title V of the CTC regs, it's in Section 80005A.
That's what happens when you have this identic memory, people get nervous about it.
It clarifies what the authorization for subject matter is for service credentials in subject areas like math and science.
On page 26 of the Administrative Assignment Manual,
There is a chart that explains what the subject matter authorizations are and then what are the subjects assigned under those authorizations that are considered related content.
That means a teacher who has this authorization can teach that related content.
So what I heard
from the leader of this school was that what she feels is material to some of the conversations and the problems that she's having with you as an example of her concerns with the monitoring and guidance you've been giving her.
is this back and forth about the authorization for her environmental science teacher.
The authorizations manual lists four different science authorizations, biological science, chemistry, physics, as well as geosciences.
And it only says for biological science, you have to have the biological science credential, and that can give you an authorization to teach environmental science.
Is there any dispute, as far as you're concerned,
about whether or not her teacher, who is teaching environmental science, has the appropriate authorization.
No.
He has a chemistry authorization.
Well, then there is a problem, because there's no flexibility in that authorization to teach environmental science.
The reason why I ask that question is because, again, that was not an issue raised in your charter or in your concern about the issues that you are raising behind why the school should be denied.
Okay, so I just wanted to make sure I said that.
So he has a chemistry authorization, which means he really isn't authorized to teach environmental science, but you are not making that as an issue material to why you said the charter needs to be denied.
Correct.
When we talked about employee qualifications, we talked about the EL authorizations was one of the big pieces we spoke about.
Yeah, and I understand that.
So the EL authorizations is one of the reasons I'm concerned about what's in the charter itself and the program description.
So I got you.
All right, I'm there.
This wasn't exactly my question, but does the charter written so that they are using the flexibility under 47605L for certification?
That's the charter flexibility for the credential.
It wasn't mentioned in the charter petition.
OK, but it sounds like that the U.S.
authorizer was holding them to no flexibility under the charter.
Yeah, there is flexibility for certain courses, but not for those core courses.
We tend to fall back on our credentialing experts within LACO when we have questions about that.
Okay.
And then the executive director talked a little bit about the change in coordinators and getting kind of advice.
Can you speak a little bit to that?
So we did have a, there was a new coordinator that came in.
I have both the coordinators here today.
Our coordinators work very closely together whenever there is a transition from one coordinator to another.
And so any of that communication in the beginning when Mr. Hartman was taking over from Mr. Brown, Mr. Brown was CC'd on all of those and they were in communication so that they knew exactly what
was being presented to the school.
Yes, I'll try to be brief, but I have been uncharacteristically patient.
My questions are actually for Lisa.
Yes, thank you.
So a couple of things were clarified, and Lisa, I just want you to nod if it's true.
The suspensions do not follow the students.
So any suspension rate reported for this school was earned at this particular school site.
Yes.
OK.
So when we're looking at this data, and for all the students that came in the administration and the new leadership, I know how difficult it is to rebuild a school culture and a school when there's been a rough transition.
So thank you all.
You're very, for the students, you're very courageous to come.
I don't know that in high school I would have been able to address a bunch of adults that are sitting up here in Sacramento.
But thank you.
Mucha suerte.
I know that many of you are going on to college and I'm very proud of you.
You make our community very proud.
The humanization of the story is what's making it difficult.
Because when I look at the scores, and I understand that a test score does not define a student, but to be perfectly honest, when charter schools appeal to their local board or to the county board or to the state board,
to make a case, they're looking at those standardized test scores.
And they're saying, we can do better than this.
That is pretty much the premise of a proposal when they bring it before an innovation, right?
But they're looking at it and saying, look, these schools are not serving students, and we can do better, and look at their standardized test scores.
So we use that in our favor, I guess, to get a proposal passed.
And we also use it to say, but that doesn't tell the entire story.
So that argument could go both ways, and we've seen it here.
Now, we have seen growth in the last year, and I think that there is a promising trend because there is strong leadership.
I will warn that I'm not convinced that we know how to serve our ELL students, our ELL students.
The fact that ELPAC was never mentioned, the fact that summative ELPAC was never mentioned, initial, just tells me that there is not a depth of knowledge in terms of how to properly serve.
And it may be it's because they're talking about four students.
But when you're trying to scale and incorporate middle school, that can be an excuse, because now you're increasing your pool of L students.
I don't think they're ready to increase and expand.
I think that if we are looking just at the high school, that changes the story, because I see a promising trend.
I am bothered, however, by our report on the promising trend from 2016 to 2017 on the SBAC data.
Why did we decide to not include students with disabilities when looking at?
So the paragraph here is, if you do not include students with disabilities, this is a percent pupils met.
And if you don't include students with disabilities, now we're looking at this percent.
I think that sets a very dangerous precedent when we're excluding a subgroup from the analysis because the next time it could be if you don't look at L's then this would have been their gains.
So look at our own memo on page
Let's see.
It's page 6 of 13, when we're looking at the review of their criteria.
Here I go.
The sections are popular today.
Section 4607.
We're giving an analysis of their growth, but we're intentionally excluding students with disabilities.
And I think that that's dangerous.
And I don't want to see that ever again in a memo, because what's next?
If you take out the Latinos, this is what their group performance would have been.
I don't know if this was our internal analysis or their analysis.
So it would help to clarify.
OK.
And I will apologize.
Where are you referring to, board member?
Our own memo, page 6 of 13.
Oh.
So in the memo itself.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Yes.
Got it.
And how many students with disabilities does a school have?
Because it doesn't have a performance color.
This was actually the school's review, so it was not CDE's review.
Okay, never a good idea to exclude a student subgroup, ever.
Cindy Kazanis with the Analysis, Measurement, and Accountability Reporting Division.
For grade 11, for this past year, they had eight students with disabilities, so we would not even provide you information on the dashboard because of the small end size.
And that I get, because we don't have the 30.
But in the analysis, what bothers me is when we say, without students with disabilities, this would be the gain or the growth.
That came directly from the school.
Yeah.
It came directly from the school.
OK.
That's, you know, no.
We just can't.
That is wrong at every level.
break and come back with our lunches and then we'll continue our deliberations.
Thank you.
I think we're going to
We're gonna try to get going here.
We've had a lot of opportunities for lots of questions and answers, and there may be further discussion, there may be a motion, so we're ready to proceed.
Who would like to be recognized, Sue?
So I'm prepared to make a motion.
I'll just say that based on the testimony and again of fulfilling the needs for students and their parents in this area I think this school fits the bill and so I'd like to make a motion to approve the charter petition of the Los Angeles International Charter School with a couple of conditions.
that we would be approving it at the high school level so for its current grade levels that are operating.
That the petition would be revised to reflect the State Board of Education as the authorizer and include the necessary language specified in the department's petition review form.
And I'll let Lisa ask questions about that or just to clarify, but many of the concerns that were raised about elements would have to be added to the charter.
And that the charter school will develop a plan to improve students' mathematical outcomes.
And that the plan would identify a support provider that's agreeable to the SBE that would assist with strategic planning and implementation throughout the renewal term.
And I think I handed out a written motion, and I believe that it's not necessary to cap the charter school enrollment, but just to be clear about operating at the high school grade levels, because we wanna make sure that they have the ability to operate effectively.
So that's my motion.
Okay, so moved, and do we have a second?
I'll second.
All right we can take discussion on the motion and I'll kick that off by just asking what could you be a little more specific about the nature of the mathematics support that you are suggesting?
I think we just want to be clear that because math performance does seem to be where their most significant struggle is, at least as it's reflected on the CASP scores, make sure that they're getting some outside advice from a provider that they can select.
It could be the county office if they chose to do that.
It could be a nonprofit provider, but that would come in with a specific plan about how to implement and how to improve
students' math performance.
Could be a professional development provider.
Could be a professional development provider, absolutely.
That's helpful.
Thank you.
Patricia, Eileen, anybody else who wants to be in the queue?
All right, go ahead.
Okay, so I do have a concern that their environmental science teacher is misassigned, and I further have a concern that the administrator doesn't clearly understand the assignment monitoring responsibilities
that she would have and there seems to be a lack of understanding about the certifications and authorizations required.
So I know that the department takes over the assignment monitoring responsibilities if this motion as you have listed is approved.
But I can't support this motion without some requirement to take a look at and address the assignment monitoring confusion that seems to be there so that we are clear.
And I want to make sure I didn't give misinformation about whether or not, as a core subject, there is no flexibility on the assignment of the environmental sciences teacher and that they must have a biology credential, not a chemistry credential.
There has to be something added to this motion to do the assignment monitoring, and if a problem is identified, some work has to be done to correct that post-haste.
I think adding it as a general proposition makes sense.
There are people of supplemental authorizations and so on, so I don't think we wanna go deep in the rabbit hole right now, but we could consider that as an amendment, yes.
There are others in the queue.
It's Eileen and then we'll go to you.
I thought you were addressing that specific issue.
I just want to ask the condition.
So I really believe there's good intent with the current staff, but I feel like they need a lot of support to
be successful, and my worry is that CDE is a small team that's trying to oversight, so I'm trying to understand what you're expecting or anticipating in the support provider role, because I believe they're going to need some support and guidance.
And I'm not sure it's only in mathematics.
And so that they get some external support to guide their work.
So, because I feel like in some ways they're disconnected with some of the newer strategies in English learners.
And I believe their intent is good, but we're gonna need to provide support.
And I'm worried that if we say we take on the authorization without specifically saying you're gonna need some external guidance here.
So did you have any plans or ideas when you drafted this about what,
Is it just in mathematics?
Yeah, that was my intent, but I'm certainly happy to entertain friendly amendments if you think that needs to be in there.
I think there are, as you know, and Member Sun could speak to this as well, there are a number of charter support providers, whether it's the Charter School Association or the Charter School Development Center, that I'm guessing would jump up and help them if they ask.
So just really quickly to address the credential piece, I thought I remember the executive director saying it wasn't chemistry, there was something else, there was another credential in there too.
But either here or there.
I would say either here or there, that's fine.
So, I just have a comment.
I think I really take to heart board member Rucker's comment about hey, sometimes we look at innovation, sometimes we look at test scores.
Where do we want to go?
And I think board member Ortiz-Lacombe said something very similar.
around how we could utilize those standardized test scores for good, for approval or not approval.
And I get that.
We have a lot of data.
We don't have good guidance.
That's in law right now.
And how do we make decisions around this?
And I dislike being inconsistent.
I just don't like being inconsistent.
I say that, however,
I think that when we look at these charters, and we look at the people, and we look at the context from which they come, there is a gestalt to this, where the sum of the parts are more than the whole.
And so when you look at it in that manner, it will swing, in my case, decisions one way or the other.
And it may seem inconsistent from one charge to another, why did you make this decision?
But I think that as educators, we know that there isn't
check boxes for everything, especially when we're dealing with human beings and we're dealing with context and situations.
So because of that, I would support friendly amendments to this.
I do believe that this charter deserves another chance.
I also think that there is a positive trend that we're seeing if we keep it at the high school.
I want to clarify, Sue, you've mentioned before, if we were to authorize as just high school and in a year we see a decline, which is hopefully not what happens if it's approved,
then what are, at that point, we also have options to revoke, correct?
So if you could tell me a little bit more about that, and also I want to add to Board Member Straus, in making the support a little bit more comprehensive beyond math, although we did see that with math, I also feel that instruction for L students could benefit from that, and maybe going back there'll be other things that they will also want to be reflective on and act upon.
Thank you.
So maybe we'll ask Judy or Lisa to clarify, but yes, we have the option to revoke if they do not measure up based on our approval and based on our expectations that are outlined in these conditions.
Yes, you do have the option to revoke.
There's specific standards and findings that must be made.
It's a two-step process.
We would have to give them a notice, opportunity to fix the problem, a notice to cure.
So it's a complicated process, but it's certainly doable.
I'd like to clarify for Member Burr, this plan would be agreeable to the SBE.
I think we meant the SBE Executive Director.
So we're not saying that you guys need to talk about this at a next meeting.
Mechanically so we would be doing a grant for one year for five years and then but there is the option if things are not going well
to revoke before the five years are up.
And for example, academic performance data would come back to us automatically just as, okay.
Yeah, I mean, just to clarify, and Lisa can do this much better, but in all of the charter schools that we oversee, they do annual reviews.
We get an annual report on how they're doing based on academic performance and other alternative measures as we've talked about.
Annually, we do an academic memo and a fiscal memo so that the board knows how all of their schools are doing annually.
So we do those memos on opposite months that the board meets.
Actually, we're gearing up now for the academic memo in June.
and then a fiscal memo in August.
So we do do those on an annual basis.
And so if there are any particular conditions about whether a year from now or a year from when the school opens, the board wants to, you know, see that, that you let me know.
I mean, we can provide whatever information you need a year in or whatever works best for the board.
I just want to make a comment, which is that I think it's very apparent from public comment what an exceptional warm and welcoming environment has been created.
And that is absolutely a unique thing to be appreciated.
It doesn't at any point mean that folks are off the hook for academic performance.
We need kids to actually be learning as well as welcomed.
And that two-step is absolutely necessary in my mind.
Okay, so what Board Member Portillo-Brownson just said is what I want to touch on.
The reason that this motion is being proposed
Let's be clear, the school is not performing well.
But the reason this motion is being proposed is because there is this human element, this issue of human capacity.
What is also being addressed in this motion is that if the school were to close, the schools and campuses these students would return to are not doing their job.
And so part of the reason behind why this motion is being proposed is because we feel compelled to let the students who came to talk to us today about their needs.
We feel compelled that we need to listen to those students.
So given that, it's a mistake to believe that approving the school to be an SBE charter is going to solve the problems of the other schools that these students could have returned to.
In a year when these test scores don't go up, they will still face the possibility of returning to a school campus where they are not safe.
and we will still be faced with the possibility that these students will choose not to go back to school if that happens.
So if we're trying to approve a motion based on the idea that we can revoke the school if the school is not improving, the reason why we're trying to propose this motion is not related at all to our priority belief in the ability of the school to approve, but it's more to continue supporting the students
and giving them the opportunity to continue flourishing in a school where they want to feel safe.
So I have a concern about that because that is the unspoken element in this motion.
But further, this motion as currently written, without all the revisions that would need to be written, this motion does not fully address all of the reasons
that the staff stated are the reasons why the petition should be denied.
Now, I know there's a statement in the motion that says the staff will, what does it say?
specified in the department's petition review form.
I don't really know what that means because I'm not clear that that addresses all of the reasons the staff gave for why the petition should be denied.
So we can feel good about creating a motion that will address all the reasons why the petition should be denied as part of the conditions for renewal, but I am not.
The premise would be that we're creating an opportunity for this leadership
to continue to demonstrate their effectiveness, but I don't believe in the promise that we will come back and revoke this school if they really don't improve, because the only reason why we're making this motion is we're paying more attention to the students than to the fact that this school is failing.
All right, Matt, you are next, and then I'm gonna put myself in the queue, and then Felicia's in the queue.
Go ahead.
Well, I would just like to say that I understand board member.
Rocker's view that is not that would not be the reason I would vote for the motion Because there is clear evidence of gain in English language arts.
It's been substantial in math It's just edging up, but there is a lot of evidence that there are plans to improve and there's a 90% graduation rate I would not approve a motion for a charter where there was no improvement evidence Partly if we vote on this it's because we see the capacity for improvement and we see some evidence of it
Matt, you're next.
So I agree with you wholeheartedly that we can debate the numbers and I remember our state superintendent yesterday saying school is not defined by a single number.
And there's so much more to what happens with a school beyond a number.
There are public schools that are struggling to improve.
This is a charter school that seems to me struggling to improve.
edge on the side of grace when it comes to improvement, when someone's had such a short amount of time to do it.
That being said, I want to make sure I understand the process here because I'm new.
When the county office denies the petition and we accept the petition, then that falls to the CDE staff obligation for oversight.
How many charters does the CDE staff oversee now?
Once the State Board approves a charter that's been denied renewal on appeal then the State Board becomes the authorizer that's been delegated to CDE staff.
So right now we have 32 schools one of those being a statewide benefit that has nine sites so we're at about 40 sites but 32 schools that we provide oversight for.
and you're responsible for bringing them back for non-renewal?
Yes.
So if the state board takes action today to make it a state board authorized school, we take over oversight, and then it will be our, well, they, I take that back.
They, at the end of that five years, would have to go back locally first, and in this case would be LAUSD.
And if they are denied there, then can come back to the state board.
I also want to echo the comments of Madam President, because for me, if we would have seen decline from last year to this year, I would not be OK with supporting this recommendation.
One, because when I look out there, I see 90%, 100% students of color and the majority of them being Latinx youth.
And so for me, when I'm looking at who is serving my community, in particular my babies from my community, I would not just, you know, just overlook the fact, and the story wouldn't motivate me if I wasn't seeing that there was a promising growth.
At the end of the day, our students will not be evaluated by what a caring school environment they had.
When they're submitting to UCLA, to Berkeley, to any of these schools, what they're looking at is a comprehensive student that has academic growth and academic standing.
And so, yes, it's important to have a safe environment.
I think the school leadership has heard loud and clear that beyond that, when we are working to build a student and we're building a safe community and a supportive community, it's to get them to the academic performance.
It's not to keep them there.
That will not help us, right?
I could tell my babies and I could tell my kids that I love them, and if I'm not challenging them, if I'm not equipping them, they're not gonna survive, they're not going to be selective, they're not gonna be competitive.
So I think that,
For me, if it would have been steady decline, there's no way that this would have been something I could support.
I'm also looking at this through this lens of continuous improvement.
One of the schools that was cited had zero percent proficiency rate in math.
Zero percent.
Another school in that community.
Okay, so we could look at that district school and say, we are going to support you with continuous improvement, but we won't do this to this school that is having some growth.
That, I'm about equity, I'm about civil rights, and I also need to balance that out.
If we're going to be about continuous improvement, then we need to extend that to all of our schools.
I agree with like everybody who spoke and you know it comes to this conversation which is really sad is that you know as oh is it not on oh okay what Ortiz and Kwon said was really true is huh oh lean it okay I'm sorry it's just like
It's very troubling to see that students of color, low income students, have to always make this decision.
If I go to this school, I'm going to struggle.
But if I stay in this school, this school still needs improvement.
And it's really hard to see that.
I see that in my community.
I see that in communities everywhere.
And we need to start doing better as a state board.
Districts need to do better.
California, the whole world needs to do better when it comes to how we're treating education.
Because I don't like this conversation of us always trying to improve things.
Like when we're talking about IB programs, AP programs, every student should have access to those things.
They shouldn't be having to fight for these things.
And so you know I wish you all luck.
I'm supporting this motion because I'm going to have faith in this school because I want to make sure that if you all don't feel comfortable going to another school I understand that.
I come from a community that's very similar to LA.
You know, I'm from East Oakland.
And so, yeah, it's just, it's really hard to see this every single year.
I mean, every single time we meet, when I'm on the local school board, and I'm just tired of it.
So I really hope that we could improve in the future.
Are ready to restate the motion in terms of what all is in it.
So I will restate what the motion is but again happy to take friendly amendments especially with respect to any support that you think the charter school might need.
But I am moving to approve the petition for the Los Angeles international charter school at the high school level.
The petition with the following conditions, the petition will be revised to reflect the State Board of Education as the authorizer and include the necessary language specified in the department's petition review form.
The charter school will develop a plan to improve students mathematical outcomes, the plan will identify a math
Excuse me, support provider agreeable to the SBE executive director who will assist with strategic planning and implementation throughout the renewal term.
Do we incorporate friendly amendments now or after?
Yes.
Because that motion has been seconded.
Member Burke can we clarify the high school program that means not the independent study it's just the high school program as it's currently constituted?
Yes.
and there were a couple of friendly amendments and we wanna, Eileen.
My recommendation would be that you just take out mathematical support provider and identify a support provider because we've identified math as a goal, but it's probably gonna include things like aligning practice to standards and teaching practices, lots of things.
So I just think if you just leave it a support provider, we'd be okay.
I'd like to accept that.
Academic program support provider including math.
I'd like to have it specified and but not limited to and Patricia Motion I can support the motion if the friendly amendment includes the issue concerning the assignment monitoring at whatever broad level
12,000 foot level, we need to put that in so that we're very clear on what that would be.
We also do check that twice a year.
OK.
And the petition review form, because I'm not sure I understand it, the petition review form addresses the deficiencies the department identified as their rationale for denying the petition.
So that would, in the way the language of your motion is right now, it would address that rationale as identified?
I want to make sure I'm clear on that.
You can say the petition review form is identified in the meeting agenda.
It's the attachment one.
Okay.
Correct.
That's what we're talking about.
Okay, if that's what we're talking about, then I can support the motion.
And I think for clarity for staff, we also think that there's a timeline for hiring the academic support provider.
So we can, that would be helpful.
That would be helpful and also if we are talking about showing improvement is there a timeline for when the board wants to see the school back before the board so we can show you where they are?
A year is too soon.
Two years?
Two years.
And to access the support provider within the next three months or six months?
Maybe before the start of the next school year.
Before the start of their academic school year.
1920.
I would say by October so that people have a chance.
By October 1.
Catch up with themselves, yeah.
Okay, by October 1.
Yeah, we're having this very friendly friendly amendment session at the moment.
I know I don't know if anyone typed it up You can try to take notes to read it So this is what I think Lisa make sure we move to approve the Los Angeles International Charter High School for grades 912 with the following conditions the petition will revise to reflect the SPS authorizer and
and include the necessary language specified in the department's petition review form as identified in the meeting agenda.
The charter will develop a plan to improve student academic performance, including mathematics.
The plan will identify a support provider.
Academic support provider.
An academic provider agreeable to the state board executive director, who will assist with the strategic planning and implementation throughout the renewal term,
This will be identified by October 1, 2019.
The support provider will be identified by October 1, 2019.
And what was the... And then come back in two years.
Okay, was there anything about assignment monitoring or is that covered within our usual?
Okay.
We'll do that every two years.
CD staff will provide an update to the board within two years of the status.
Is that right?
Is that what you want an update on?
Okay.
to see what the academic performance is.
Okay an update on the academic performance in two years.
We have all the features of the motion.
We have a motion and a second.
Yes.
We've had discussion on the motion.
I'm gonna call for the vote.
I'm calling for the vote.
Superintendent has a comment.
Madam President and members of the board, we understand your intended direction with this motion.
I would like to ask if we could also, if you all would be willing to make a statement of intention so that it isn't just waiting until October to have the provider in place.
But that sooner than that, the school would have identified a plan for improvement.
And the reason I'm asking that you suggest sooner is that if they have trouble getting the plan in place, that we would rather know that sooner rather than later so that we can assist them and provide technical assistance.
As it currently is now, to be honest, the staff at the CDE, as it relates to the oversight of the state board schools, at best can do one visit per year.
And so if it's already been identified that there are performance concerns, we would wanna know sooner what their plan is and where they need help sooner so that we could assist.
And so- We may wanna say as soon as possible and no later than.
Thank you Madam President.
Thank you.
One last comment before we go.
And let me say I appreciate the superintendent for making that statement, especially given what the annual LCAP approval cycle is.
The charter itself already has to get their approval done by the end of June so they can submit their plan to the county office or their authorizer by July 1st.
So that pulls us into this conversation anyway.
So there should be some intentionality on what they're going to be submitting to you
as the new authorizer when they submit their LCAP to you as the new authorizer.
So we should see something sooner, as soon as that, because they have to do their revised LCAP plan and turn that into you.
So we don't even see the corrections we've identified, like they put the LPAC in instead of the CELP.
when they turn their new LCAP into you on July 1st, that lets us know, well, we still have a problem with the urgency that they are taking to address the conditions we've put in.
So I would make sure that you tell them, these are some things, at a minimum, we would like you to make sure you revise and submit in your LCAP when you turn it in on July 1st.
I don't know if we need to put that in the motion, but it's very clear that that's gonna be the first immediate step.
I think we can offer that as guidance, and I think the motion is pretty full of words.
So we have a motion, we have a second.
Hearing no further discussion, all in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed say nay.
Any abstentions?
All right, motion passes.
I'm gonna bang the gavel.
I'm going to go on to item 17.
Let's clear the room and then we can.
We appreciate your enthusiasm.
We do have to go on with the meeting so if you can celebrate in the hall that would be a better place.
Take it outside.
And in just a moment I'm going to recognize our state superintendent for a little
Statement announcement.
And by the way, I hope your daughter's 13th birthday got off to a good start this morning.
Yay.
Terrific.
I know.
I want to make a comment about how much gray hair and how much hair I have left.
As she points out, not much.
Just wait, just wait.
Thank you, Madam Vice President.
As you all prepare to give your reports, we would be remiss if we did not acknowledge that this is likely the last board meeting for our Deputy Superintendent, Tom Adams, and we would not want him to leave this meeting without being roasted, I mean acknowledged.
I've got to work on my talking points for his long-standing service here at the department.
You all know that he has most recently served as a deputy superintendent for the branch that has programs like special education and English language learners and
nutrition and other things, he has extended his retirement through the end of June to assist us during a period of transition and has been filling in as the deputy superintendent of the branch that includes assessment and data and measurement that was previously headed by Carrick, who also recently retired.
We thank him for that.
What you may not know is that his journey at the Department of CDE has run continuously some 22 years.
Wow.
That he came to the department as a consultant in 1997 and has risen through the ranks and served in a number of capacities as a director and as a deputy superintendent.
I've only had the last five months with him, but I can tell you he's someone with a lot of experience, wisdom, and knowledge who is deeply committed to young people.
If you didn't know that, if you needed any more proof of that, he has served and continues to serve as a school board member in the Davis Unified School District.
And he's given me the honor of swearing him in in his most recent term.
I think that the school board member and being a state board member, I think it is the hardest job in politics.
I really do.
Because people mostly show up when they're angry.
And when great things happen, sometimes the chamber is quiet.
But I also think it is the most rewarding job that there is in the political environment and in an educational environment, to be able to set policy and direction for students, to be able to interact with students.
And Tom's heart is very much about the students.
He went out and greeted some parents yesterday who spoke here at this microphone during some of the very difficult times.
And he made it his point to go and greet them.
I think he's a true reflection
of a leader who gets that what we do is all about students.
And I didn't want you all to not have the opportunity to share whatever you might want to share to Tom.
Now, we're hopeful that we can get him to delay and defer again.
He spent a little bit more time with us, but I'm sure that his family, his wonderful family wants more time with him, and maybe he wants more time to devote to his school board duties.
So Tom, on behalf of all the staff at the department, our chief deputy superintendent, Lupita Cortez-Alcala, all of the deputy superintendents, the 1,500 staff here,
the entire network of some 2,500 staff all across the state and all of our partners.
Thank you for your service.
Thank you for being a part of the CDE family.
And congratulations on your approaching retirement.
I would love to.
I didn't know if I would have a chance.
You know, I came to the department in 2003, and I always found Tom Adams as just super respectful and very professional.
He knew his business.
He knew curriculum frameworks, and I can always take him to the Capitol.
I had no problem.
with talking points, keeping them on message, or anything like that.
He is truly loyal, but not just to this agency and to the people he's worked for, but to the students.
I'm really proud not only to call him my professional colleague, but a friend.
I grew up here, and he was always there to lend a hand, to give me advice, to help me.
And I just want to tell you, Tom, personally, you have been one of the best people here at the department that have not only helped me, but really helped us do great things, and I'm sure that there's innumerable
frameworks and standards, and now you're in assessment world, and that you have contributed to, and you have personally contributed to and negotiated and probably been deposed one too many times over, I don't know, little things like history.
So I just want to thank you for sticking with it and helping us out and helping me out yet again and this administration, but I just have so much deep respect for you and so much,
love and kindness and and I will forever thank you and remember you for your for your kindness and your help.
Thank you.
Okay, so I just wanted to add that, yeah, so despite Tom being a board member and deputy superintendent and all those other things, he never left the classroom.
And I saw that when he came and visited my school.
And the light in his eyes, the energy he had, and the immediate connection that he had with students, I could tell he was still a teacher at heart.
And that's really what energizes him and drives everything, and that's what we are about.
So I just wanted to,
to also highlight that about Tom.
Well, I just want to express my congratulations on your retirement, Tom.
We will definitely miss you.
I've actually known Tom probably for all of the 20-some years that he's been at the department.
And I just want to say that some of you know this.
It was mentioned yesterday.
When I came to be executive director of the state board when Superintendent Torlakson was still here, it's safe to say there was a little bit of a rocky history between the state board and the superintendent.
And it was my goal to make sure that we didn't have that kind of relationship going forward.
I know it was all of the board members' goal that as well.
And one of my most effective partners in turning that around was Tom Adams.
And Tom was fantastic.
He held up the curriculum and framework division through very difficult times when we didn't have any money.
He helped us point in the direction of the Instructional Quality Commission.
And I think it's safe to say that our instructional
and learning program in California would not be the same today if it were not for Tom Adams, and I will forever be grateful to you, and I hope that you get season tickets to the Giants.
So I just want to say as a liaison to Instructional Quality Commission, I really got firsthand to watch Tom's leadership when he was, because he was Executive Director of the Curriculum Framework Division for 13 years.
So what we saw as a result of the health framework work that we did yesterday, all the processes that the Curriculum Framework Division leads was developed under Tom.
It's all the background work of how you track public comments, how you go through materials review, what the criteria is, how you bring people on, how you orient the Instructional Quality Commission.
All that is really to Tom's credit.
And I watched him very, very closely, as many of us have, on the different frameworks, as we did quite a few together.
And Tom has a particular expertise in history social science, which was definitely
And so, I would say that as we look back, because we had a five-year hiatus during the recession where we didn't do any frameworks, and then what we were able to do under Tom's leadership and the processes that we now deal, we deliver,
Really, it's to your credit.
But beyond that, it's just the collaborative, cooperative work we've done together.
Tom and I sat on a panel with the deans of the schools of education, and Tom, with all his wisdom, said, in your courses for teacher preparation, why aren't you just using our California frameworks?
They're free, they're online, and I think I just sat next to Tom so proud as a panel member talking about what we need to do to prepare teachers.
So thank you for all your impact and leadership, but your legacy really is there and lead on in all of our work, and it's been our pleasure, really, my pleasure.
Well, Mr. Dr. Adams and I met just in 2015 when I was appointed.
And I have to say that, well, now we're Facebook friends.
So I think we're at another level now.
But I just have to say, you're funny.
in a very quiet way.
You're a very caring person, and that just comes across.
And I think for me, you're so approachable and accessible, right?
And I think not just for us, but just to your staff.
Obviously, the room is, as we introduce this or as superintendent introduced, I started seeing people coming in.
So that's a testament to your leadership and the type of person that you are.
Thank you for being so involved in everything that has to do with English learners in particular.
I have to say that I don't only see you in Sacramento, right?
If I'm in San Francisco for a conference on ELLs, you're there.
If I'm in Long Beach for a conference on ELLs, you're there.
And so it's probably not surprising when people are involved in something that pertains to this building, but when they really care about a student population, when they care about an issue, they go beyond the boundaries of this building, and you've done that.
So thank you for bringing voice and visibility to some of our students that are often not at the table.
Thank you.
Well, Thomas, I started my work in doing this policy work the same time you did.
And the first time we met, we were at a meeting concerning the criteria for the English learner materials.
And Jackie Goldberg was the convener.
So we've been on this journey and on this conversation for a very long time.
I don't have to worry about repeating the flowers and the accolades and the attaboys that you've heard from my colleagues.
I just want to tell you, as an English teacher, you know me,
Rudyard Kipling wrote in the poem, If You Can Keep Your Head About You When Others Around You Are Losing Theirs.
I had a student who got so emotional in saying that poem, he said, then maybe you just don't understand the situation.
But that's the one thing, every time, from the moment I met Tom at that first meeting with Jackie Goldberg, that was the voice and the poem and the thought that came to my mind.
I have seen you laugh.
I've seen you cry.
I have seen you work to build consensus in a room full of people who just weren't interested in agreeing with anybody.
I've seen you play charades badly.
Nevermind charades.
But more importantly, I have seen you walk the talk, not only with us as board members, but with your staff in the way you lead, in the way you guide, in the way you mentor, but with stakeholders in the way you lead, in the way you guide, in the way you mentor.
People don't just respect you, they admire you.
And my members, when I go into meetings and I mention your name, the whole room goes, ooh,
because they really appreciate not only how you made them, how you do the work and how you validate the initiatives of what it is you're giving to them, but the fact that they know you were the one person who not only heard them, but you understood them and you gave action to their concerns.
So even though you have little teeny tiny feet, you're leaving really big shoes to fill.
You're leaving some really, really big shoes to fill because it's very hard to come in behind someone who has done this work as well as you have, not because it can't be done, but because there's just going to be a disappointment because it's not you who's still doing it.
So even though
You're going to be gone and even though I know you're leaving us in very capable hands because you have mentored some very strong leaders in this department and you have created a role model for how to do it well, you will be missed.
I personally will miss you and I have your phone number so I can call.
Not only I have your phone number and I know where you live, plus I've met your wife and she likes me so I know it'll be okay for me to come and visit.
Before we close, I have something I'd like to say as well, but I don't know if any of the department staff has snuck in here.
We're particularly interested in making any statement.
I thought you might, Kristen.
You just had that look about you.
Well, as I have mixed feelings, because
Tom is no longer my deputy, but during the time that Tom was, I have to say, and even before that, we have really been working hard in the state to really become more of a coherent system.
And the only way we do that is by having great partners and great leaders who understand that from the core.
And I guess that's what I would say in terms of reflecting not only about just a personal relationship with Tom, that he's been an incredible mentor and friend, but also that he's really helped our system to integrate in the ways that we'd always hoped it would, that general ed, special ed crossover.
So thank you.
We're going to miss you around here.
I'm not going to say more because I'm going to start crying.
And so thank you for letting me have this opportunity to say that.
I want to just kind of close us off, as I was thinking about you Tom and you know what could be said about your leadership I was remembering a quote which I've just called up from Congressman Gus Hawkins who was, you know, a long time ago the father of Title One and
one of our great Congress people from California.
And he said, the leadership belongs not to the loudest, not to those who beat the drums or blow the trumpets, but to those who, day in and day out, in all seasons, work for the practical realization of a better world, those who have the stamina to persist and remain dedicated.
And I think that's you, and we really appreciate you, Tom.
Don't retire.
Well first of all people will really swoon when my CDE the movie is done and George Clooney plays me.
I think we're both a lot alike.
I mean that modestly.
I have to say, though, when I came to CDE, there's a couple things I always say to people.
The first thing, I had moved from the world of academic research, doing a history dissertation involving four different languages, French, German, Polish, and English.
So when I came here and started reading the code in English, my first reaction was, wow, this will be a lot easier.
And then, so I thought I was pretty hot.
And then the person who taught me how to read the Ed Code was Sandy Adams-Jones.
She was a person in CFIR, a great person, recently passed away.
But she had no more than a high school education.
But she knew the Ed code and taught me how to read it and the subtleties of it.
And here was someone with a PhD going, oh.
And so it was an early lesson in my career that you can learn from everyone in the department.
And I can say, Kristen, thank you.
You taught me so much about special ed.
Veronica Aguila, who taught me a lot about English learners.
And there are other folks along the way, all the great staff in CD, and also the commissioners.
It was called the Curriculum Commission and the Instructional Quality Commission.
They were great in terms of enriching my perspective and it kind of reminds me of, you know, what I like to do on my spare time is read, join this reading group and we do it over the phone.
It's called the Reading Odyssey and we read classical texts.
It's the only way I've ever would have finished these studies or, yeah.
I mean, I really have to ask someone saying, you know, we're going to talk about this, right?
Oh, yeah, I better finish reading it.
But anyway, so this spring we read Cicero's On Obligations.
And people always say, well, you know, compliance and accountability, those tend to be bad words.
But if we actually rephrase it,
in the concept of renewing our obligations.
And here is something telling us we need to be doing something about it.
And maybe we're not doing it well.
So that's why I took that inspiration.
Anyway, Cicero talks about goodwill in there.
And one thing is he talks about goodwill as not measured by intensity.
He says that's a mistake of teenagers.
Goodwill is measured by steadiness and commitment.
And we know in the education business, it doesn't all happen in one day, right?
We say at a minimum, it takes 180 days in this state.
And we also know that many of you in your capacity as teachers, there's always a student who comes back to you five, 10 years later and says, you know what?
I wasn't very good in your class, but this one thing stuck with me, and it really helped me out later.
So it's part that.
And it's also the sense, there's another great part where he refers to a Greek philosopher, Aeneas, who says,
If you have a lamp that is lit and you light another, it doesn't mean your lamp is that much less.
You have made the room that much brighter.
And that's really what we're all about, right?
We're about making the room brighter, making sure that when they leave the room, that they can take that lamp with them and light that many more.
And really, that's what education is about.
It's about lighting those lamps and making sure that others can enjoy that.
You know, looking back on my career, I had a lot of great opportunities and privileges and so many things to learn.
I started as a contract employee under the Honig administration.
Yeah, yeah, I know.
I really am from the previous century.
And then Delane Easton, who happened to end up later in life as my neighbor.
Jack O'Connell, and then Tom Torlakson, and then now Superintendent Thurman.
It's amazing.
It's a great thing to be in.
And it's really nice when a job well done is measured by how well your students are doing.
There's not too many other places in our economy where that's how you measure your job.
And that's pretty rewarding.
And that's why we keep doing this work.
Yeah, it's never easy.
But if it wasn't a good thing to be done, then we wouldn't be here, right?
So thank you, everyone.
You have to go to item 17.
But go to item 17 we must.
Thank you, Tom.
So we are almost at the end.
State Board Projects and Priorities, which is here for action and information.
The SBE staff recommends that the SBE approve the preliminary report of actions and minutes for the March 13th, 14th, 2019 meeting.
Do we have a motion?
I move approval.
Thank you.
Any discussion?
All approve, say yes, yay.
Any nos?
All right, any abstentions?
I was not here on March 13th, so I guess I should abstain from March 13th.
And now we have SBA liaisons.
Yeah, you should abstain.
Yeah, because you weren't here.
So you don't know.
You don't know if it was accurate.
All right, so we have two and a half abstentions.
Okay, so we wanna hear from SBE liaisons who wanna report on their activities that are not related to any items on our agenda.
And we'll start with Sue Burr.
I'll just report briefly on the work of the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence, CCEE.
We met on April 4th.
As usual, we had a lot of very informative presentations about the work.
The one I want to call out is we did a spotlight update on our professional learning network.
Some of you may know that we fund in the neighborhood of 50 or so professional learning networks.
and we had two of them come and make a presentation.
They were very powerful.
All of our meetings are streamed, so if you're interested in seeing it.
But I just have to say that the thing that struck me the most was one of the professional learning networks is led by Butte County, and Butte County brought a principal from Paradise who continued to participate in the professional learning network despite the fact that he lost both his school and his house.
So it gives you a sense of how powerful that experience is for principals learning from each other.
So kudos to him and to Butte County.
Our next meeting will be June 6th here in Sacramento.
I think it might actually be at the department.
I can't remember.
We kind of alternate between here and SCOE.
As always, everybody's invited to attend.
Thank you.
Yes, good afternoon.
First, I would like to acknowledge something big that happened in the Oakland community recently.
So on April 3rd, on 26th Avenue and Foothill, three people were struck by a hit and run.
Alma Vasquez, a mother of three, and six-year-old son, Angel Garcia Vasquez, a kindergartner in International Community School, also known as ICS, as well as Jamie Garcia, Angel's uncle, and a newcomer student at Fremont High School.
who's still in the hospital recovering, I wish him one hope he can recover soon.
This impacted the whole community as we saw a family be killed and their members hurt because of their loss.
This should have never happened.
Angel is the second student to be killed in this school due to a hit and run.
The first student, Anita, she was killed while some of my peers in my senior class were in elementary school.
And my little sister and cousins go to the school, which shares the same campus as ICS.
And so in my personal life, I saw my little sister be impacted by this death.
She is only six years old.
The whole community on the campus, which is ICS and TCN, as well as Jamie's school, Fremont High School, and the Oakland community in the whole, came together and marched.
We marched for their lives and for the city of Oakland to put a light in the corner, where even Noel Gallo, the district board member for that area, came.
And, you know, it was because Alma and her baby were killed, Angel Garcia.
And so, however, this is a sad story.
I'm way too familiar with these things.
My community is way too familiar.
Since I was young, I heard of people and my community members get killed and people I know personally.
And these are stories that I wish and many of us here wish weren't real, but they are.
And we need to acknowledge them.
And I wanna ask that we give a moment of silence for Alma and Angel and everyone impacted by his death.
So.
Thank you.
I want all of us to remember their names, Alma, Angel, and Jamie, because these are people we serve.
Angel's a student that we all served before his life was taken away, and Jamie is a student that we are going to serve as soon as he gets out of the hospital, as well as their peers and their siblings who are going to this school still.
Angel has an older brother who's in fifth grade, and has a little sister who's one year old, who we will be serving in the future, and I want to remember them too.
So after hearing that story, my last two reports have been about things that impacted communities greatly, but I feel like it's very important because these impact our students.
Now moving on.
In Los Angeles, the LA Unified School Board voted to allow 16-year-olds to vote in their school board elections.
This is exciting to hear and I look forward to how this impacts and continues in other districts.
I'm not sure if everyone knows this, but Berkeley Unified actually allows 16-year-olds and 17-year-olds to vote for their school board elections, so I'm excited to see how that moves on to other communities.
And I would also want to talk about a situation that happened in Vallejo that went viral.
A student named Natalie Ramos in Jesse Bethel High School
was the first Latina to be named as the school valedictorian.
However, for the first time, all of a sudden, when she wanted to be valedictorian, the school wanted to give the title to nine other students with her for the first time ever.
When the original policy states that only one student was supposed to be valedictorian, and so she posted this on Twitter, her sisters and her mother, and it went viral all over Twitter, Instagram, Facebook, thousands and thousands of people across the country were sharing it.
So after a few days that it went viral, her GPA all of a sudden got lowered.
And she got turned into third place so that she wouldn't be valedictorian.
So she posted that along with the rest of her family.
And so because it went viral, she got put back to rank one because they're like, this is too much attention.
And I myself spoke with Natalie Ramos and her family.
And I wanted to make sure they were OK because she's a student that I represent.
And fortunately, after everything that happened, she will be
the valedictorian on her own.
I'm very happy to hear that, you know, as a fellow Latina, if you have a title, you deserve it, right?
People shouldn't change it only because you're Latina.
It doesn't matter your sexuality, gender, race, ethnicity, you should get that title.
And so Natalie Ramos will be going to UC Berkeley next year, so I wish her luck, and I'm excited to see her thrive.
Another thing I wanted to acknowledge is that in Oakland I attended two honor rolls, the Middle Eastern honor roll, which is the first one ever, and the 19th annual Latino honor roll.
And there was also the second annual Asian Pacific Islander honor roll, and next Monday there will be the African American honor roll.
And these celebrations are very important because we are highlighting students who are doing great academically, but not only that, we are telling students you do not have to shut down your culture, you don't have to reject your culture,
and have to give up everything you're about in order to be successful in your community.
So all these events, they always have people, alumni, they have people who do cultural performances, they have people who speak, and they all do things.
And so I was the keynote speaker for the Latino Honor Roll.
It was a huge honor.
And I was also a guest speaker for the Middle Eastern Honor Roll, which is very exciting because it's the first ever, and I'm excited to see how it moves on the next year.
And another student who spoke is a senior at Life Academy High School, Mohamed Alolefi,
who spoke about the importance of Middle Eastern culture and acknowledging it and acknowledging the diversity and how it has contributed to society and so it was really amazing and Latino honor roll we gave specific awards to two students I want to highlight Jovanna Salana who spent much of her time in speech therapy and special education classes from kindergarten to eighth grade.
With perseverance and hard work, she made valiant strides to remove some obstacles in her way that stood in her way.
Little by little, she made progress and built a community of teachers, therapists, and counselors that provided her with guidance, and support, and motivations to excel in her studies.
And Giovanna actually became the first student to be reclassified as a student with IEP in Oakland Unified School District in her freshman year.
And in her freshman year, she started A through G. And next year, she will be heading to East Bay College University.
And so I'm very excited to see her thrive.
And we also acknowledge Aparicio Lorenzo, who's an amazing student leader, a newcomer from Guatemala.
He was our parliamentarian for All-City Council Student Union.
And he will be going to UC Berkeley next year.
And so I'm very excited to see Aparicio thrive as well.
And yeah, that concludes my report.
Thank you.
No, I survived.
Thank you for making the transition well.
And I want to thank Karen, Staff Walters, and the staff have made this transition and my helpful understanding as to what my role is in the process.
So I appreciate it very much.
Thank you for letting me be part of it.
So you saw a lot of my reports yesterday with 211 public comment speakers.
I'm the healthy ace on.
And I think everything went well.
So I appreciate everyone that came.
I want to start with a really high note for me is Teacher Appreciation Week.
And I'm very happy to report that I am married to a teacher.
So I want to appreciate, for me, the best teacher in California, Mr. Robert Licon.
who happens to be a Latino in elementary.
And I know that's one of the superintendent's initiatives.
My husband is one of 7%, I believe, elementary school teachers.
And he came to this field a little bit out of...
Well, he wanted to be a pediatrician.
That was his life goal since he was a young boy.
And OCAM did not help at UCLA.
So like most first generation Latino students, he was not encouraged to persist, and instead ended up in sociology, but had a love for science and a love for kids, and thought that he would bring those talents to the elementary school.
And he was also a young father.
Sometimes we don't choose a career, but the career chooses us.
And he's been faithful to that career for 21 years.
And he will be recognized by Assemblymember O'Donnell as Teacher of the Year for our district.
So I'm very excited, yeah.
Yes, and also just kudos and celebrations for all the teachers.
It is the toughest but most rewarding job that we have in career.
OK, so liaison assignments.
I'm also the liaison for the ethnic studies model curriculum.
I forget the name of our group, but our committee has just completed their third meeting.
The model curriculum will now be going to the IQC.
So that will be that process that will now be followed, and I am sure I'll be coming back to you with a lot of reports about the model curriculum.
As EL liaison for the state board, I spoke at the California Association of Bilingual Educators along with Mr. Dr. Adams and I also sat on a panel with Lupita.
and Dr. Daisy Gonzalez from the chancellor's office.
I know Tom was there to support us.
There was two men, Tom was one, and everybody else was women because it was women leadership in education.
So that was a great opportunity to learn a little bit more about Lupita and her journey through the educational system and some of the things that she does now in her leadership at the State Board or at the department.
I also want to thank State Superintendent Thurmond who will be visiting Long Beach Unified School to celebrate the dual emergent program and that will be happening June 7th.
So we are very appreciative and honored that you've accepted the invitation to come to Long Beach Unified.
Thank you.
I'm also delighted to have survived and had this sort of first experience of the last two and a half days.
Yeehaw.
Actually, I'll build on one thing that Hema was talking about earlier, which is there has been an incredible amount of violence, I think, that so many kids throughout California have been
dealing with.
I think the current events that you were describing in your own neighborhood and what we heard earlier during the conversation that the kids at the high school witnessed someone actually killed in front of their high school.
And then also, of course, having in the immediate rearview mirror the gun violence in Colorado.
And just acknowledging that our kids come to schools with so much trauma and the degree to which we are both asking educators to heal our kids as well as teach our kids, and that is a big load to carry.
that I'm delighted that we're appreciating teachers this week and recognizing them, not just for the academic work they do, but also the work that is much more close to familial love than what we oftentimes think of as at the forefront of their work.
in the spirit of also thinking about love, both my mom and my husband's mom are both educators, and so today is actually my mom's birthday, and I know she's gonna be listening on public access, so I just wanna say happy birthday, mom, as well as happy appreciation of Teacher's Day, and the last sort of work-relating thing I'll just flag is that today is an important day for me,
legal folks tell me if I'm not allowed to talk about political things but today is may revise budget day and it's very exciting that the governor has Proposed a I think a newfound importance for early learning for our overall system of support for learning and
starting in the 0 to 5, acknowledging the connections with the state board, and also with our school systems, which provide so much of the backbone of early learning already.
So I'm excited that is moving forward.
And happy May revise.
We have lots of revenue.
Well first, taking a moment of personal privilege, earlier this week I acknowledged the contribution of one of my own teachers, Angela Tolson.
I want to acknowledge two others, Ted Sanders and Arthur Prince.
These two men were African American educators who chose to teach in an elementary school
and give up professional options to be an engineer or to work in science because they wanted to teach and have the opportunity to teach.
They're important to me not because they were my teachers, but because they were my brother's teachers.
It is true.
that African American boys need role models and need important role models and relationships with the people who stand in front of their classrooms to teach them.
And my brother thrived as a student and as a man because of the relationship he had with those two people.
So I want to make sure I acknowledge them.
I'm the liaison for waivers, so for most of you, that's really dull and mundane, not really exciting stuff, but that's the reason I rely on and get a chance to work very closely with a lot of staff in this building to do that work.
Every waiver in the state of California, except for class size, comes across my desk and we have a long conversation
in preparation for the things that you take two minutes to vote on, not even two minutes to vote on, but I want to thank the staff for the diligence and the initiative that they show, not only in preparing the items, but in the research and the outreach and collaboration with the districts they work with.
But in the time that I have spent, as you saw over these two days, we need to do some work on updating the policies that guide the decisions that we make on the waivers.
And so this is something that I'm going to be working with the staff to undertake and to make sure that over time I'll come back and report to you
some of the work that we're working on in doing some of those things.
The other two things that I work on as a liaison, I'm going to rely on my colleague, Board Member Sion, Board Member Strauss to report on, so I will leave that to them, but I do want to close with one other report.
You may recall we had a student member who came from Palos Verdes High School.
As you see from each of the student board members we have, and especially the one we have here, each of them leaves a fingerprint, an imprint on this board and on the work that they have done.
And one of the things that he left behind was a relationship with this board.
Each year the PTA and the school site council at his high school does the fundraising to allow a group of juniors and seniors
to have a multi-day field trip to Sacramento.
They get to visit with their representatives in the Assembly and in the Senate.
And this year, they even got an appointment with the speaker.
I still wanna know how they did that, because I can't get an appointment with them.
But as part of that relationship, and as part of their annual visit, I'm always invited to participate in a Q&A session with those students.
And we get to talk about education policy,
They ask me questions about the activities of the board and the work that's going on in Sacramento.
And these are very well-informed individuals, and they're always very excited to come to Sacramento and do that work.
I had an opportunity to meet with them again this year.
It's a wonderful thing to see and to know we have wonderful individuals who come and sit on our board.
It's another thing to see that the districts where they come from are expanding the opportunities for a lot of students to be engaged and continue doing that good work.
So we're the beneficiaries of that particular relationship and so I'm always very happy
to represent the board when those students from Palos Verdes High School come and I'm looking they've already asked me to hold my calendar for their field trip when they come here next year as well so I want to thank them but I also want to acknowledge Hema
One of the things we take for granted when we are leaderships and in the work we do, that sometimes we suffer the slings and arrows of a great deal of abuse.
And as the point was made, people don't always come here when they're in a good mood.
They come here to yell at us.
I think I want to give just a particular shout out to Hema because she's learned some of the hard lessons of leadership and about criticism.
And the fact that sometimes that criticism comes from people who should know better.
and who should behave better.
It's always shocking and is always of a surprise, but I just want to say, Hema, we got your back.
And for all the students who come here to this boardroom and to these meetings who choose to be brave and to stick their neck out and to stand up
and to advocate.
I applaud them and they are truly my individual heroes, but Hema, you in particular, are my personal hero and I really want to make sure I get a chance to say that to you.
So I'm going to try to highlight a few of the liaison areas.
One is I liaison to Credentialing Commission and I just want to highlight, those are a two-day meeting, but I just want to highlight a couple areas that particularly relate to teacher preparation and issues that we talk about in our goals of improving student achievement.
Quite a debated and
advocate discussion about the reading instruction competency assessment called the RICA.
Very strong, it's an outdated teacher performance expectation that's based on legislation.
There's pretty strong a desire by most people to do an update and to take a look at whether course requirements and a new
an appropriate way of showing reading preparation that's aligned to our adopted standards rather than the old ones.
So we'll hear some more about it, but CTC, you heard a lot of discussion, and there seems to be an agreement that this needs to be addressed.
So I thought I'd bring that up.
Also, so we got the benefit of the former CTC chairman, Linda Darling-Hammond, to be our state board vice president, and so there's a new CTC commission chair, and that's Dr. Tina Sloan,
who's been on CTC for 11 years, delightful.
She does teacher education at UC Santa Barbara.
She was appointed by Governor Newsom to the higher ed seat and now has been elected unanimously as the chair, so very fortunate.
She has 11 years of experience on CTC and I think will be a great chair, so delighted.
And then we talked about the state-funded grant program.
So under Governor Brown, there'd been money for trying to look at preparation, recruitment, retention, and support for California teachers, particularly in the area of special education, teacher residency, and grants to support that.
And so we have a lot of agencies and districts and start charters looking at residency programs.
And so they'll be really trying to look at preparation and developing the pipeline.
So I thought I would share with that.
And then also,
The Career Tech Ed area where we talked about in the College and Career Indicator, there's a work group that talked about some updates on that as well, so we'll hear some more.
So those are some highlights, lots of discussion at CTC, but those are things that are actually related directly to credentialing and things that affect the work that we do, although teachers affect everything we do.
I was very fortunate to be on a panel, LA Unified is a large school district with a huge number of women leaders and they have annual conference with women leaders and actually Wes Smith from AXA facilitated a wonderful panel around the voice of women leaders and advocacy and I was very fortunate.
It was held at Garfield High School, I'm actually really close to.
Yeah, it was really fun and exciting opportunity.
And then we talked a bit, Sue was talking about the professional learning network.
So I got to speak after CTC here in Sacramento at the CSBA has a professional learning network.
And so there's groups of superintendents with board members and district and the teams that come together
We talked about the dashboard, the update, the idea of community engagement, and also the issue on capacity.
How do you build capacity and stay focused?
Really engaging conversation, the superintendents and their board members really talked about what is community engagement.
And so just the idea of the work we do here at the policy level and watching how it's engaged.
And I was fortunate on April 22nd to go to the CORE advisory, and Matt's been part of that program for a long time.
But CORE is actually a group of eight districts, and it's actually 10 years old.
It was established in 2010.
It has large school districts.
And so just an interesting thing, because I think they're a really good incubator for the work that we do around strategic use of data, bridging research policy and practice, and looking at improvement knowledge.
And so just to highlight,
And then there's some links on their website I'm glad to share, but I think they really can help inform some of our work.
Talking about equity, talking about districts collaborating together.
And so there was a panel from Sac City of principals talking about how they deal with continuous improvement at their school sites.
And then a district team that talked about how they support principals.
Obviously my role having served in both those roles and coaching principals and district leaders now, how do you give support for the people out on the line every day?
So they have some really interesting things.
So one thing, as we look at our dashboard, we're talking about being prepared, highly prepared, what that would look like.
So they have some interesting titles that they capture.
Post-secondary competitive is the highest level.
That's what they call it.
Then they say, then you're post-secondary promising, high school graduation ready, vulnerable, or at risk.
Just interesting to think about as far as how they categorize it and what categories they use.
They use a lot of different data systems and they have a really interesting program looking at freshman success and really looking at what that means and using lots of analytics.
the freshman on track program that they're doing and some of the metrics could be helpful and informative as we look at what is good.
Those of us who've lived in high schools, what are good high school practice?
How do you catch kids before they get too far behind?
What kind of analytics in transition from eight to nine?
What are relationships and things that matter?
So, I know the core districts are doing some really wonderful work that I think are really helpful and they are part of our stakeholder groups just so you're aware of, so they do share some of their practice.
Then I'm part of the Standard Steering Implementation Committee.
It's really a dozen of us from CDE, state board, and the county superintendent's office talking about where are we on standards implementation.
So two communities of practice that are worth thinking about.
They got private funding from Bechtel.
over a four-year period.
They're only a year from finishing and WestEd's been studying it.
But it was a model to try to build capacity across our counties.
So they have regional teams that come together.
They meet three times a year for a couple days, build their learning with the understanding they have to go back to their county offices and their counties and try to improve.
So, it was a slow process to get started building regional capacity, but there's WestEd's finding some interesting promising practices, but they talk about the stuff we talk about, which is equity and access, support for students with disability, particularly area of science.
They actually use Sanger to take a look at their work with universal design for learning and NGSS.
All those resources are available.
So, I just thought it'd be interesting and be aware that there was a science community practice and a math community of practice,
They have another year before the grant ends.
So over the four years, Bechtel will have put $10 million into expanding capacity for math and science.
And still, we're taking a look at and we're starting to touch classrooms.
How are we helping to build that capacity?
So really important.
The last thing is the Standards Steering Implementation Committee, which met last week, is talking about how do we sustain this over time?
What's the role of the leads?
What's the role of principal support out there?
What's best first instruction?
How do we help that standards-wise?
And how does system of support differentiate classroom support?
So there's a lot of work and I think trying to get a sense of this giant state and how we support standards implementation, how do we build capacity from pre-service to different stages of people's career and the leaders to support it.
There's a lot of discussion that's going on.
So that ends my report.
I'll be fast.
So you all we had the item on the Perkins transition plan as you know.
So that's passed.
We will be oh sorry it's the workforce pathways advisory committee that I'm reporting on.
We did have a meeting scheduled for April 22nd.
Unfortunately we didn't have a quorum so we ended up not having that meeting.
Our next meeting is May 29th.
I'm also going to be attending the Board of Governors, community college Board of Governors meeting on May 21st to report out on the work of the joint advisory committee.
And so that's that.
Since it's teacher appreciation week and everybody else took personal privilege I'm just going to really quickly give a shout out to Mrs. Brimner who was my middle school English teacher who when the counselor tried to put me in remediation English because as some of you know I had EL problems when I was younger.
What's that?
restraints, that they tried to put me in the remedial English class and she insisted instead to put me in the accelerated English class and here I am today.
So that, and then on the other end of that, just tonight I actually was very pleased to be invited by a former student at my school, Noel Mora, to speak at a student, at a panel around the LCFF and it's a student group
that's interested in policy.
And he sent me this email, I hadn't heard from him in three years.
He sent me this email with this title, it said, President and CEO of the Associated Students, Inc.
at Sacramento State University.
So I was just quite impressed with that at all.
So that's what I'll be doing tonight.
In the spirit of recognizing teachers, I wanted to recognize three teachers.
One I thought about when we were doing the health education framework yesterday was my kids' eighth grade health education teacher who taught them about sex education and drug education.
And they call his name, Mr. Einhorn.
To this day, they thank Mr. Einhorn for everything that he taught them.
So I want to thank Mr. Einhorn.
I've been reading a lot about the research that shows that African-American teachers are particularly important for the long-term success of African-American students, and two of my kids had the privilege of studying with Fay Freeman in the third grade, who was the motivator for everything that they did thereafter, and we saw that.
in action and Fay Freeman and Evelyn Jenkins-Gunn who are both board certified teachers.
Evelyn single handedly detract Pelham High School as an English teacher and made sure that all the kids were in the Regents classes and passed and they are heroes for us and our family and I think representative of the wonderful teachers we have in our country and in our state.
So with that, we took public comment earlier and that, do we have any, are we done?
All right, so I hereby adjourn.